One, two, three.
[inaudible].
So
the demand, Leonard Skinner, the actual
man landscape died. Is that what happened?
Yeah, I guess he was like a
gym coach. Hang on, let me
eat this Mike Condoms. Yeah,
he was at on them free day. He was, yeah.
Evidently the gym teacher that they
named their band after. Really? Yeah.
So He's dead. That's it. That's a
wrap. We all go folks, uh, this,
this show as all are sponsored by the
fleshlight. Uh, if you have not tried one,
Doug Stanhope, and I know we were
discussing this before the break,
but we decided to save it. You have
not, I have not fucked a fleshlight. Oh,
you're still a fan of masturbation.
Everything.
Only in the most clinical medicinal,
like quickly get this out of me way.
You don't spend any time like lusting,
no lust, no. None whatsoever.
When did that stop happening?
I gradually over years, I mean,
I remember even at the man show,
I'd fucking no interest in the jug ease,
just so dull. At a certain point in
time in your life, you're forcing it.
If you're still chasing it, you're forcing
it. It's like, what are you doing? Yeah.
Well,
I remember if you had told me a 20 are,
you'll lose your sex drive it like what
would you do if you weren't trying to
fuck people like,
and then you'd think at 43 what could I
have done with my life if I wasn't just
trying to fucking blow
loads and chicks? Well, I,
I definitely haven't stopped beating off,
but I see where it's ridiculous.
I just want to to cam ones by the way.
Huh? I just fucked one of the canned ones.
Totally different than the other one
was like a drunk, sloppy chick. Oh,
it's really sloppy and loose in our
own flashlight. Get on that shit. Oh,
it was good. It was a manufacturing
issue. It's mixing up your bitches.
It was good. It was meant for a
different kinds of Brian. It's,
this is what it's meant for a girth
here. See, it looks like a beer and a,
you opened up top and it's a fake
vagina. That's the idea behind. Good.
I'm Brian is not a fan of this one.
I fucked up.
I fucked a rubber vagina once and blew
a load in it and then fucking just put
it,
put it away and then a couple days
later I grabbed it and it fucking stunk.
Like all get out to look at this one.
It's a, it's a fake vampire. Yeah,
that's the, it's a vampire mouth.
The twilight series. All right.
What is wrong with people?
If the aliens didn't need more evidence
that were retarded and it's time to land,
look at this fucking thing. Look at this
thing. Can they see it? Yeah. Come on man.
Really
wake me up by your mouth that you
fuck what? Yeah, they're good though.
They're great. Very good.
As far as masturbation since
or anything, I'll try one.
And if you think about it in terms of
just being pragmatic and doing body
maintenance,
when you shoot a load with this,
you're going to shoot a bigger load and
it's going to take a couple more days
for you to build up.
No one could call you a sellout for this.
Like I asked all traps blue ribbon sponsor
a tour and I like switch beer and for
a minute like I've got, oh,
it's, I'm going to get drunk
anyway. Who gives a shit?
What kind of beer? I'm
drinking, not selling out.
There's something about Pabst blue
ribbon that's become cool again.
Like the fact that it sucks.
It's, yeah, it's, it's, it's
been that way for a while.
Yeah. Yeah. The fact that it
blows is the selling point. Yeah.
It didn't used to be right. [inaudible]
hipsters to the poor thing. $3 PBR.
I just don't like drinking out of
cans on stage. That was my big beef.
Get a fucking bottle.
There's a dude as a comic in New York
named Jon Tobin and um, when we were, uh,
I was living, I know that name. He's does
a radio show and a, I think in Buffalo,
someone upstate New York.
Anyway, yeah. When we were, uh,
I was in my early twenties, we
got fucking wicked drunk on, um,
on 40 ounces, like black beer, you know,
like old English and track
man cobras one size 18.
And I had just moved to La and
we drank that, I don't know,
maybe three of them and I was
passed out on a sidewalk. Yeah,
we had these and we watched a show a of
the movie superfly and did commentary on
supply.
Just two white guys talking like black
guys drunk out of their fucking mind of
forties on forties it's a
different kind of drunk.
It's a reckless trunk engineered by the
government. It's pretty, pretty clear.
Alex Jones was saying that
something is given men estrogen,
which is causing men to be gay
was like toothpaste or some shit.
It was one of my favorite ones.
He's ever die manager.
Said he saw you on an Alex Jones.
I haven't seen it yet,
but he said it was hilarious how you'd
bug to the camera when he was going
fucking crazy.
You just look at the camera and go.
Well it was a double whammy of crazy
cause I was on with Eddie Bravo and he
probably wants to talk about
chem trails because Eddie Bravo,
I love him to death,
but any problems convinced that the
government's spray and shit on us.
It's a fucking crazy story and I even
tried to come to Eddie Bravo with some
science.
I said,
well I know this dude who's a pilot and
he explained to me that those clouds are
created by a certain amount of moisture
in the atmosphere combined with the
turbines at the jet engine and it creates
these clouds. That's what happens.
But this video's on youtube,
man, his videos and he just
won't buy it, man. He just,
he's convinced. So here we are.
I'm trapped. And Alex Jones,
well I'm doing a documentary
on that right now.
The government is definitely spraying us.
It's a hell of an Alex.
And then Eddie Bravo is going jam once
this documentary coming out and I'm going
fuck
spraying the population like they have
that day. When did he do it at night?
There'll be a lot of people. The
airmen. Yeah. This is a giant.
He's this cut to syphilis.
Yeah. Yeah. That's what it is.
A giant one for the whole population.
It's not really working.
It's kind of a real slow process but
there can to keep the spray gun trance.
Have you ever seen those up?
Like trucks are good on your street and
spray for bugs and like in the middle of
the night like that more
scary cause that's really,
the government definitely has worked on
some weather. And don't get me wrong,
I mean I think for sure they have
sprayed people at certain point in time,
you know there's video
when people can say,
oh there was some shit and I'm sure
they probably tried it. I mean,
but it's probably very specific areas
and the V for a very specific reason and
some fucked up experiment that didn't
let the people know they were in on.
But I'm sure they did it or not doing
it every day here too, aren't they here?
They're getting sprayed onto, yeah. Yeah
man. But I'm immune to that shit. Yeah.
He posted this one photo that was really
crazy. And then I went and I was like,
wait, where was this photo taken? Airport?
No, no, no. It was right next to lax.
And I'm like,
cause I found a store behind him was like
the stores that I googled the name of
that store.
And I found out that he was right next
to lax when he took that photo and on he
believes in it.
Man,
he believes that they're a man who
knows really bad on his show because I
couldn't really like, you know,
bust on him cause I know him.
We've known him for years. Jones. Yeah.
But I couldn't take them
seriously and I couldn't,
he was evidently thought I was coming
in as more of a on his side guy.
Yeah. Cause he hasn't seen me
since we did that Kevin Booth DVD.
I always try to find
things that I do believe.
I try to be as friendly as possible with
them. I really like Alex as a person.
He's a fun guy. I enjoy going to
the, we went to the fights with them,
we ate with them, we hung out with
him. He's a good guy. He's just,
he's just crazy and all
wound up and everything.
So I was trying to find some common
ground where I actually agree on them.
Like I always bring up some stuff like
you know like a operation Northwoods.
Yeah. That's the one. That's
the good one. And you know,
of course you can get into
the Kennedy assassination,
but that gets a little gray.
It's like, who knows what
really happened there. Yeah.
I can't put together last year very well.
So fucking the further back in history,
the more open to interpretation.
There's some shit though.
That's really interesting that, uh, that
he turned me onto. One of them was, uh,
uh,
one called operation midnight climax
where the government ran brothels in New
York and in San Francisco and where
they did LSD, LSD. Yeah. That's John's.
That's true. Yeah. And he turned me on
to that and I was like, wow. And again,
once you see that those things are real,
Northwoods and mk ultra,
all that, yeah. Then you go, well,
they could be doing anything and then
you realize, I don't give a fuck. Yeah,
I agree.
It doesn't affect my day.
I've been coming to that exact same
conclusion that there's certain things in
life that you're putting all your energy
towards and they're not helping you at
all. Right. You know, nor
are they stopping anything.
You're not helping the cause,
you know you're not out there,
but you know,
but it is worth I guess pointing out so
that maybe someone somewhere along the
line here are some of the shit you say
and laughs at it and thinks maybe know.
It's almost even
one direction or another.
It's almost like being at a
magic show and being able to go,
I know how you did that. Yes. All right.
You're still going to have a show.
I'm not going to fuck up your whole Vegas
experience, but I know how you did it.
So chicken based on some
comics yelling that out.
Maybe it just makes them up their game.
Maybe that's all.
It's something that stuff I'm interested
in, but I had to stop with that.
Making yourself so Alex Jones, like
where you just get crazy. Yeah,
I'll be at three o'clock in the morning.
I'll be fucking clicking on some link
about some new loophole that Goldman Sachs
use and some fucking Matt Taibbi article
and I'm just going fuck me to stop your
business knowing not only that, I
don't, what the fuck am I going to do?
What am I gonna do? Am I going to devote
my whole life to this? You know, I could,
shit I like to do.
Yeah.
I want to know how many times Alex
Jones shows up at a city council meeting
about fucking streets sweeping laws.
There's some not something he can affect.
Yeah, that's interesting. You
probably doesn't ever do that. Yeah.
What about do that Doug?
Stan hope.
But right now demons are
ascending upon our government.
They are deep embedded in our
political system. Doug Stanhope,
you go on the road,
you'd tell your jokes,
you think all swell and good
because are you dying FEMA camps?
So don't worry about the volume mean
birds. I was trying to do my, uh, my,
uh, I can't do it. Well, what's his
name? Fucking conspiracy theory. Oh,
just Jesse Ventura that show they
conspiracy theories look so bad.
Like we don't realize there's Rumsfeld,
he's trying to tell me that the
Kennedy assassination might have been,
yeah, one low. Not Real.
Well, no, they overproduce it.
So he sits down with his
writers like and they,
they hit them to some conspiracy
that he's not aware of,
but I'm going to go right up.
And then he's surprised that a former
governor just can't walk into the CIA and
look at fine whenever he wants.
The former pro dumb founded,
this was reduction of here's
where your rights are going.
[inaudible] gentleman who talks like this,
this is how we're a little bit of a
load in his mouth just to, just to,
just like he looked at Tim,
let's just floating around with her for
middle shoulder governor from Torah.
Did you see him on the opiate Anthony
when Jim Norton tore him apart? No,
no I didn't. Fucking beautiful.
He got douchey with Darren.
He got bullied with Norton and the last
thing you should do is get bullied with
Norton. Cause that's what people have
done to him his whole life. And he's like,
fuck you. He was like physically
intimidating. And when,
when he's talking about like a legitimate
question about nine 11 or whatever it
is, conspiracy theories, and
he's legitimately questioned
him, you know, in a, in a,
in a, in a a really not a condescending
way at all. And Torah gets fucking crazy.
And then Norton gets crazy
back and Ventura winds up
leaving and walking off the
shot. What do you want to hear it? Do you
want to hear it? Yeah, here we go. Yeah,
let's put it,
it's great because it's like
the most comics were picked on.
Most comics were,
would do shit
around when we were younger. Yeah. And
the last thing comics like is a bully,
right? You know, if someone like this, so
this was like, when I, when I heard it,
I immediately texted him and called him
up and when I saw him I said it was the
most awesome thing I've ever seen.
It was beautiful because Jim Norton is
a fleshy ball of 150 pounds and Jesse
Ventura is a fucking former navy
seal, his big giant head. And he's,
what was he getting in his face? He
just got stupid with them. You know,
it's like the way he describes things.
If I take this out of the stand, well no,
he's not the God damn comic. Good. Can
I keep trying to lean into it? Uh, yeah.
Yeah. The stand is an awkward situation.
This whole couch was a terrible idea.
I mean,
I need something.
I can't look over there because not
only do I not like to see myself,
but it's a delay. So I'm seeing myself
minutes ago. I'll have to look at it.
I'll show. All right. Yeah. I
don't like looking at fucking,
we used to have a chat in the chat.
The problem with the shadows,
who would be like, fuck good.
shop.call. Calm, calm, calm.
Like the chat would be flooded,
bigger tech.
Suck my dick or tick like a hundred times
in a row. And you'd be like, Oh God,
it's such a fucking outlet of hate.
The whole Internet.
I never like Google search my
name or anything like that.
Oh, that was awesome.
That was Google saying
cos he smirked. Be smirk. He's Marcus.
Every fucking show I do.
People will yell out to every show,
every show,
but fuck it if people are yelling
shit out. That's of, and that was,
I never even really did. I talked about
it on stage a few times, but yeah,
I heard the,
the audio,
you talked about the time that you and
I did it where I thought you were going
to die, but every fucking show, like
it was like my closing bit for here.
It was a,
there was one of the weirdest psychedelics
situations for the folks at home. Uh,
Doug and I were doing the man show and
it was like in the death throes, right?
It wasn't right. Yeah. Here we
had to spend all night writing,
trying to save the fucking thing. We knew
it was a disaster. We got fucked. I mean,
look,
we,
we both appreciate the fact that everybody
was disappointed by how that show
came out, but no one was more
disappointed. And we were,
the whole thing was a mess. And look, we
don't need to get into details, but uh,
if you, unless you want to, no, no, no.
It's, yeah, it's over. Was terrible show.
But there was some great shit in it.
I defy anybody to watch the uh,
my midget sketch. You what is it?
Another man's midget cause your,
your sketch a defy anybody to watch
that and tell me that's not hilarious.
Where are you trying to steal the
old mentioned from the man show.
Bring them over to the middle. Knew we
had shared with us, I mean it was a,
it was the wrong thing at the
time because our show is not a,
the learning experience was priceless
cause that was my first real television
and just knowing how they fuck it up.
We could have,
we could have done
something on the Internet,
we've could have done something like
Internet style where there was no input
whatsoever and we could have had a
great fucking time. Right. And when,
when they came to me with the idea,
the idea was we're going to have nudity,
we'll blur it out immediately.
I'm thinking Joey d is going to be naked
at the beginning of every show is just
telling someone about that. And then the,
and then I said on what? About squares?
And they said he could bleep it out,
bleep out, talk about whatever you want.
They go,
it's a good thing if we get sued,
this is what stone Stanley guys tell me.
If we get sued, it's a good thing. Yeah.
I'm like, we are gonna
fuck shit up. I'm like,
I'm just can't wait for
abortion monologues in chaos.
And when we got in there,
it was totally different story.
As soon as we got in and the audience
wouldn't have liked it any better. No,
they would've still hated it,
but we wouldn't have had the fuck.
We would've had the bags on our heads.
We would've had to rebuild and
make a new audience. You know,
there was one point in time with John
Stewart didn't use to host the daily show.
Right. You know, people forgot there
was that other guy and it really,
we shouldn't have called the dementia.
We should've said,
we are really into the idea of taking
over that time slot or that idea that
doing this new show. What? It told us to
pound sand probably go fuck ourselves.
Yeah. Yeah, they were,
they were convinced that that name was
going to sell everything and that was
going to be the big push and there's
name brand. I'm like, it's it,
but it's not the same. Sheldon at the
same guys, they're not here anymore.
None of the writers are here.
What the fuck you talking
about? Can you do it? Fear,
fear factor, 14 hours a day. That
was, I got so greedy. I was like,
I am going to have two shows at the same
time and I was just thinking this stuff
up, that money I could never
work again. Never work in again.
I'm never working again, but that
was a dumb I down. Terrible idea.
You should never do more
than one television.
If you didn't have to work would
you stop? No, not stop doing.
Stand up and maybe, yeah. I
like doing the UFC too, man.
It's nothing I do right now is really
work. You know, between Standup, I mean,
I can or I can regulate how many times
a year I'd go out and the UFC. I,
I look forward to it. It's fun. It's like,
yeah, what am I going to do this weekend?
I could stay at home and I can go to
the movies or I find it Indianapolis.
I want some dudes beat the fuck out of
each other from five feet away and I get
paid for it. I get to call. It
does, it never feels like work,
but if it was like a sitcom
or something like that, yeah.
Do you got to shut it off for a, did you
get, did you guys want to hear that? Uh,
yes. Yes. Yeah. And then what's, let's
reintroduce this. Okay. I, this is,
so this is Jesse Ventura
and opion Anthony,
Jim Norton and him get into an argument.
Right?
Okay. I'll talk to y'all. [inaudible]
can you hear that? Yes. Okay.
Cheryl, that yes, bodies identified.
Ah, well we'll just fly
with that. What the hell?
My government told me that. So you
know why I don't believe my governor.
You believe Saudi Arabia's go go
over there flying planes around.
But here's why I don't
believe my government,
my government is lying to me so many
times they lied to me about the Gulf of
Tonkin incident. Isn't that
pretty important? Be like,
I want to go back that far.
You want to go back to far
with the Kennedy? We can't
go back to avoid via dog.
You said to me, we were with those,
got all the shopping in 2004 pounds.
So we're not going back that far.
We said we send our guys off
to war without giving a shit.
And I'll tell her that's not true. I
agree with you. When did you go to war?
I've never been in the door and that door.
So you don't know.
But I say pull them out of everything.
So because I've never been in the
military when we are attacked by I feel a
nation, we should not, it should be
proven first. I feel we proved that.
You feel we didn't.
Do you also feel that fucking Bush was
behind nine 11 so we're always going to
disagree.
Go put fucking words in my mouth.
You feel that the u s government
was behind it and I didn't say that.
Josh. I met covering it out where
you have not been told the truth.
So you feel like, well, okay,
wait a minute. All right.
If you'll call them down in a moment,
you're yelling. You said the ads, right?
When you're the governor,
they slot
bring you up to yours. You know, wish I
saw that you said about,
you know you're not going to let me talk.
I'm out the door and talking.
The whole time while you're doing is
yelling for people and you don't want to
address point by point. You Act like
we say, send our boys to our fucking,
we've never said that I agree with you,
but I want to pull them out of Jeremy.
I want to pull them everywhere.
The U s military should never
be dying for other countries.
I don't care for Roya
happened. Scan them. Outcome.
I don't care if Kim Jong Il bikes itself.
That's not my business.
I just think that if we were attacked,
we have the right to
honor military to respond.
So that's not something warmonger
saying fuck the voice. Send them over.
That's what I want to
see.
It just sits and looks at Jimmy.
Why Awkward?
That was a fair point I just made
you were wrong when you said that.
I don't know.
I didn't listen.
I talked over you. Yes. Nutritional
yelling at me cause I'm not talking.
I'm not yelling at you. I'm just telling
you about your point. You would shoot.
It does. It's something. So let's say that
you guys are just full of Shit. You're,
you're warmongers. You know, it's
like that's not the truth. Yeah. Yes,
I stand corrected. Thank you.
You're a great American web.
How much have a great American,
but I'm not a warm in their country calls.
You're there. Hey, I've never been in the
military. So you're brave. I'm a coward.
I have no right week.
Let me stop there for a second.
Stop there for a second. You know,
if you ever listened to something and it
was a long time ago and you have it in
your head as being one thing and
then watch it again and you go,
wait a minute.
Well I remember when they had the loose
change guy on there and they fucking
decimated them. But he's not
a, he was not a performer.
He's not integrative physician
to those guys. The fucking,
there's so many New York guys and
I think Jimmy Norton is funny.
He's a great guy. Off the cuff,
probably the funniest comic.
What I saw when I saw the video was I
originally, I must've not seen it all.
I must've saw just Jimmy shouting him
down and he walked out of the room.
I must not have seen the debate that
went on to discussion that went on before
it. I must not have,
cause I remember that.
I think I just remember him standing
up the point we're about to get to.
I don't remember that part at
all. If you watch, I just watched
the most dangerous man in America. The
Daniel Ellsberg story. What does that,
it's a,
he released the Pentagon papers.
He was a top advisor to the Pentagon
during Vietnam and knew that it was all
bullshit from the Gulf of Tonkin.
All this secret shit that we were doing
and release the papers to the New York
Times, uh, is, uh, Nixon called him
the most dangerous man in America.
It's,
and it was like 20,000 pages of all
the fucking lies that were told about
Vietnam.
And you watch that fucking movie,
Jim Norton and tell me that they don't
send people into fucking to die for no
reason other than political.
Jim Norton is a good guy,
but he's a Republican.
He's got like this right wing lean
to him. It's a lean, you know,
he goes conservative and I think he does
it because he gets support from them.
And I think he likes it. And I liked the
idea of it. And, and, and he's correct.
Absolutely.
Though a lot of people who are liberals
who call themselves liberals are whiny
constantly to shut the fuck up. Oh yeah.
No, I think liberals fuck up more stuff.
Way More in my day, in my, my,
my own personal life. Yeah.
You can't smoke in bars.
That's not Republican. Yeah.
You should be able to smoke
wherever the fuck you want.
If a bar decides they're
going to stop smoking,
and I understand it for the
patrons that worked there,
but you can find plenty of
patrons at smoke and if they want,
they want to quit while you know what?
They should quit the job and quit smoking.
Okay. You can't be around smoke.
Right. I totally understand your point,
that it's bad for your health,
but there's people that do smoke.
It'd be more than willing
to take those jobs.
At the old days when I was playing pool,
we all pool halls were smoking
and I didn't mind. I liked it.
There's something about
it, man, and I'm just,
I'm using that as a frivolous example,
but it was the first one that came to my,
but the, as far as the nanny
state itself is concerned,
that's mostly liberal policies. Yeah. He,
so it's Norton's anti
liberal and he's right.
There's a lot of Cottey fucking throwing
their cigarettes out of their Prius.
How many fucking times have you seen
that? I've seen that seven times. Yeah,
it's cause it's so ironic.
I always go a number five.
The fucking guy throws a cigarette out
of his Prius the other day with a meat is
murder bumper sticker.
I want to just fucking grab
him and pull his head off.
Just just rip it right off his fucking
week spine to shut the fuck up.
So I understand where Norton is
coming from. I understand this,
this rebellion against, but it's, there's,
there's absolute proof that the
government has put people in harm's way.
Absent proof.
They're profiting off of relentless proof.
Not just a few aberrations but relentless
over a course of time repeatedly.
And No, you don't know about it until
long after the fact years. So yes.
The fact that I, I would,
if I had to bet money,
I would say on some level nine 11
was an inside job on some level.
But what they do is they take every
possibility and combine them though as
though they're all actual fact.
They were not really planes.
What we're seeing our drones, ladies and
gentlemen, if you look at the bottom,
you can see the box very clearly.
I'm
looking at two pixels. One
Gray, one's white. I don't
know what the fuck it is at.
All. I fear is like there's no parts of
the plane that went into the Pentagon,
but yet you look at a picture and be like,
there's this big parts and say, well,
you know, yeah, there's
fucking broken wheels and shit.
With that plane hit the Pentagon for sure.
There's a video of it.
He was living and people
who like to do video,
it was only like a play and I'm like,
fuck, do you know it's one frame,
things going 500 miles an hour and it
slams into a building and explodes.
And why do you think it's a missile?
It can be anything I'd be at somebody's
throwing a football, you know,
it doesn't matter.
Like there's little things like the fact
that they show a lady hanging out the
whole of the World Trade Center where
the plane made a whole waving for help,
but you're, and you're
thinking just logically, okay,
if it's hot enough to melt steel,
how is that woman sitting there
and address waving out the window?
How is she not on fire? So stuff
like that. Yeah, that, yeah.
Maybe there is a scientific
explanation for that.
Well that is disinformation
is all about right.
You say some absolutely ridiculous
things like what people don't know,
ladies and gentlemen,
there were Ufo is stationed in New Jersey.
They needed a distraction
to get out of the state.
They'll add shit like that to shit.
That's real.
And then will that get all up?
That's what Jesse Ventura's show did
for everything it was talking about by
being overproduced and
acting like he never right.
Are you telling me that problem?
Are we better get out? Go file.
Wait, this is your TV show.
You just walked in and you didn't know
what it was going to be about. Well,
you know,
once you're on the set,
what are you going to do if you're
Anthony Bordain, you gotta eat the snails.
Hey you are you on for another nine 11
thing was the the amount of people on
those planes cause you and I,
we fucking fly for a living.
And why you go there at like 30% capacity?
Like how often do you get on a fucking
plane where there's only a third full?
Yeah, very rarely but all
of her essay. So again,
there's things that made me, you know,
brought up buildings, seven questions,
building seven's the big one tonight.
Building seven's the one and I don't
claim any knowledge. Okay. This is,
people get all frantic when you start,
you're questioning the
fucking official story.
So what are you a truther you wouldn't
have fucking known living truther like
you cannot be interesting to me. I don't
give a fuck. I didn't, I don't know.
I don't like New York.
I was in Irvine last night,
fucking horrible spectrum center,
this adult destination mall
and I said around, as I said,
a fucking nine 11 happened here. I don't
think it would make national news. Maybe,
maybe one local guy would write a letter
to the editor complaining about how it
ruined his reservations at pf Chang's.
That's pretty funny.
But yeah, I'm interested, but I don't, I
don't care. It doesn't affect my day. Um,
well I, I, I'm fascinated
and I'm interested in, and
I do care. I know, you know,
all jokes aside,
a lot of people died there and
people knew people who died there and
you will die everywhere all the time.
And it's crazy that you wear,
we don't such an influx of knowledge
right now that you can go online and find
some shit that you should care about.
And I had to fucking cut. Um, I,
my list is full.
You have to care about enough already the
connections that were supposed to have
the people that we don't know because
they were born in Connecticut as opposed
to people that we don't know that were
born in Iran and not buying that. That's,
that's where it gets ridiculous.
It's like with the connection
of information that we
have with the Internet,
at a certain point in time,
they're not gonna be able to keep selling
the whole idea of, of a, a planet or,
or have a, an individual
country or an individual state.
They're going to have to eventually just,
we're, we're going to have to go to one,
one CR, one world government.
Yeah. I'd have to, you know,
pro new world order in that sense.
Yeah. We have to be the same thing.
We can't be fighting over
each other because you know,
this guys are like a million people
die in Iraq and ember goes, hey,
as long as it doesn't happen over here,
but it is that is over here,
this over here, over
there. It's the same thing.
It's the people you don't know there
were born somewhere else who fucking got
jacked like yeah.
And if we tore down borders,
I could stop caring about
people closer to me. Yeah.
It's like you get trapped in that whole
idea of, you know, this is my team,
these are my people and you know, someone
fucking plays a country music song.
And throws up a flag and I'm
man, fuck it. It feels good.
It feels good to be in
right. All right. Feels good.
God bless America feels good singing
around with a bunch of other people and
you're all drinking.
Where are resilient people?
How has that fucking baddest
mother fuckers on the plant?
Wu on July 4th I didn't blink
after [inaudible] and you're drunk.
And that's how people get recruited.
That's how, that's what happens. You know,
you shouldn't be great if,
if generations didn't overlap,
what do you mean to carry on the nonsense?
That way if there was a great ever,
if people like we just showed
up now with all the, you know,
the basic skills, motor
skills, you know, instincts,
but we still had the innocence
and ignorance of a baby.
Like one generation dies and then the
next day the next generation starts.
So they can't pass down
ridiculous notions like nations.
And you ever stop and think when you
see all this crazy shit and this is what
I'm on lately.
They ever stop and think about all this
nonsense that keeps carrying on despite
the access to information that we have.
And you ever look at it and go,
maybe this is like a natural pattern.
You know,
I've got this thing I've
been tripping out on about,
and like animals and natural instincts.
I'm like,
we look at like wolves and we see
the Alpha, the Beta out of the pack.
We know he'll likely die on his own.
And we go, hey, you know, that's just,
that's it. It's hard as fuck to be a
wolf, you know? And they have to do that.
That's natural. And we look at bees
making beehives, that's all natural.
But we never look at ourselves as the
direction we're moving in his natural
juice. Maybe possibly super
fucking incredibly complex,
but ultimately natural.
And this idea of, you know,
that we have so much control and
so much power over our future.
Maybe that's a crock of Shit May,
may be the reason why all this nonsense
is in place is because that's like a
little,
almost a universal order to keep this
process moving in the direction it's
supposed to be moving in as what? I
probably didn't get the word in edge wise,
but with Alex Jones, he would say he was
trying to make the point because I am a,
you know, hugely against
procreation and uh, he was a, well,
you know how the fucking,
if we don't keep making smart
people than fucking dumb people,
if you're going to have a fuck off,
yes, she will always be out
numbered. And eventually, yes,
smart people don't have to exist.
What if smart people stopped procreating?
Then you give the earth to the dumb and
you don't fucking create poor bastards
who have to suffer in it.
I used to think until I had kids,
I used to think that like procreation,
like who gives a fuck?
What are you gonna make another person?
Does it matter? And then once I had kids,
I started realizing,
well, this can be fun.
You can enjoy the shit out of this and
he can make these little happy people and
it makes your life more happy and it
makes their life have you get a chance to
make this little person
a raise them happy.
I don't claim to have any information
about what the fuck is going to happen to
the world and although
our take your scent,
your your similar cynical view
that you know we're fucked.
We're going on a certain
road, overpopulation, the
pollution of the environment.
Nobody seems to care the corporatization
of these small countries and fucking
rob them of the resources and pollute
them and this and that and war and fucking
chaos and where the fuck is it all going
to go? I'm not completely convinced.
I don't think I have the answer.
I don't think I could have ever imagined
that this could have taken place.
If I was a monkey.
I could never imagine that we'd be
doing a fucking podcast right now,
just sitting in my office just shooting
the shit and it would spread through the
Internet and you can do whatever the fuck
you wanted and that this would be the
kind of thing where
you could reach people.
I get emails from people from Australia,
from fucking Tanzania.
I get Italy, China. I get emails from
all over the world. Somehow or another.
This has had some of them say, you
suck. A lot of them do. I suck in China.
Most of my emails honestly,
are really positive.
Every now and then I get some Umea.
You a youtube douchey ma'am,
but I like to think that it's always
one guy too. There's this one guy,
the only way Douche always.
What my point was that I could never
have imagined this taking place,
so why am I pretending that I know
how this is all going to turn out?
Why am I pretending that I have a
little fucking do man, it's coming.
You know apocalypse too for
sure. No, not necessarily,
but that's when I stopped giving a fuck
is when I realized I'm not going to
procreate. So it doesn't
matter. Duncan Trussell mind,
fuck me last week and that was
it. Monday, when do we do this?
We've got Dunkin Monday,
Monday.
Dunkin mind fucked me on Monday
by saying something like,
how do we know how long
we get to live for?
And he was talking about reincarnation.
He was like, maybe we live forever.
Maybe reincarnation is you live this life.
And then you know,
you think you're fucking going off
a bridge and a truck and you know,
you wake up from the dream,
you're like, fuck, I almost died,
but you did die and you're
just in this new thing now.
And this is life with embedded memories
and embedded ideas and you keep going on
and on. And there's times where I stopped
back and I look at my past and I ma,
I'm not convinced that was me.
Look Dude, see these right here.
These are all my, my martial arts metals,
these are all from taekwondo tournament.
When I won the US Open and a
silver medal in the U S Cup,
we had a problem. Please gentlemen,
you know what to make me hard sign. Um,
but anyway, I don't believe I run those.
I don't believe I really used to do that.
I don't believe I know how to do it still.
And I,
I'll go out and I'll hit the bag and
something or something like that and I go,
oh, I guess I really know how to do that.
Like somehow I know that's in my head,
but I don't believe that that's
really me. You know, that was,
that was so many years ago. It's a
different human being. Your fault.
Every cell in your body is
replaced every seven years. Yeah.
You know what's weird about
his, uh, in theory, by the way,
I thought of it as a
afterwards, unfortunately, but
I understand what he's saying.
Where you, you, you, you wake up
and you're like, oh, you know,
you might've just re born or whatever.
Right.
But you're still getting old the whole
time. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
He might be right. Be The memory
of you getting old is this life.
You don't know whether or not the memory
of you getting old is just taken from
another life or not. You have no idea. You
have no idea how long you've been here.
It's all nonsense.
Every time you wake up,
you're trusting that you're on the same
track in the same game that you're,
you know, on the, in the
same fucking movie. And then
the same. Yeah, there's the,
every time you wake up, look,
everybody's scared to die.
But nobody is scared to go to sleep.
And they ultimately seemed to be
the same thing. I mean, chemically,
they're even the same thing.
Your brain produces DMT when you're
in rem sleep and they believe it also
produces it when you're about to die.
And they think that's responsible for
all these crazy near death experiences.
And you know, you've had the empty, you
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
If you didn't know that that existed and
then someone was trying to describe it
to you, they would do it. No justice,
right? They'd be like, you could talk.
You could talk all day.
You can't now. Yeah. It's,
you can't describe it is what you always
say before you try and that shit's
happening to you every night and you're
going to die and that shit's going to
happen when you die. We don't know. We
don't know what the fuck we are. We don't.
We do not know. This is real. You assume
that it's real because I'm, I'm agreeing.
It's real and your ingredients real
and we're all in a room together,
but this is all just trust.
I'm just trusting that you guys
were even fucking real. You know?
I'm trusting that.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm trusting that this this day that I
woke up isn't some new life that I just
started because I was some fucking trucker
in Iceland and I went into a frozen
lake. You know who the fuck knows?
You're the only one they exist to.
Couldn't be like everyone else is
just like a part of your brain.
That's the theory.
There's a lot of people who subscribe
to the theory that the reason why the
world is ending is because your life
is ending and your life is really the
creator of this universe and this universe
all exists in your mind and as you
get closer to death,
the world becomes more and more fucked up.
Fascism and fucking government
control and their chips in my brain.
Really it's always old people that
do that the most. Sure. It's not like
it was your, not like you were those
old people by the way are in your mind.
How about that?
How about those old people aren't even
real and the old people in your mind that
are playing this fucking game out with
you. Yeah, but uh, if you knew that,
if you knew that was the case, it would
fucking ruin your day. What it though?
I would still enjoy the fuck out of it.
I can still enjoy it.
Like it's just a strange ride. Groundhog
day though. He didn't enjoy that. Yeah,
but that was different at the same
fucking life over and over again.
Brian's not talking about slightly
different every time. Saying, if I, if I,
if I consent that you are just part
of my imagination and I'm creating you
[inaudible] that would suck.
Well, the real question is
what the fuck? What a guy,
what would wake up every day? Go?
What should I have Joe Rogan, dude,
I made them up. And that's
not just me. It's you. You're,
you're living in your imagination.
I would hope that I have
a better imagination than
why it's fucking fantastic
list if I am,
let me tell you something right now.
If I am just a player in your imagination,
I am honored at what you've created.
Like fucking fly across the room. Oh
No, no, no, no. Brian in the chest. No.
I imagine like,
no,
you've done an amazing job with your
imagination as a bit player in your
imagination.
I just want to tell you,
thank you very much for everything
you've created the pores. It's brilliant.
It's brilliant. It's brilliant making you
blow smoke up my ass. You, you're right.
You are the master.
You're the man behind the curtain.
Don't even know what I'd have you say
if you were in my imagination. Listen,
you've done an amazing job what you've
done in Afghanistan, the quagmire.
You know what I really love?
I really love the drug war
references that you throw into it.
The fact that we're over there in
Afghanistan and they produces 90% of the
world's opium.
I love how you may be my imagination.
Not only would you be
heaving compliments upon me,
but you'd you'd give me Vaginas
to in a can to fuck fucking
Dick. I want to thank you for the pouty
lips stuff. Yeah, man. I love those.
My space pictures that you created.
I love how you made Justin Bieber.
Justin Bieber's brilliant brains,
right? When you think it's over right?
When you think it's over. Well, there's
no begin to be no more, no more, no more.
Boom. A new one. More ridiculous
than ever before. He's a fucking I.
I don't know why.
I know I have to know who that guy is.
I don't watch any shows like that.
I don't even listen to music,
but I know who Justin Bieber's I don't
watch gossip fucking shit. It's yeah,
it's something you could bury me in the
ground under eight feet of fucking soil
and leave me there like a fucking David
Blaine trick and I would still somehow
find out who Justin Bieber is and not
know why. I don't know why either.
I haven't even heard his voice.
I don't need not even know what his voice
sounds pointing. Get Yogurt with him.
I don't know what he looks like.
I just know the name and he's
a big pop sensation. N N.
Dot com I go to for my mainstream news.
Okay. I go there and there's an article,
Kim Kardashian upset
about playboy pictures.
She's upset because some pictures when
she posed for playboy in 19 seven got
released and somehow
they're on the internet.
That's like tiger woods getting pissed
off because they showed a fucking old
golf game. Right. You know, like
what the fuck are you talking about?
This is like real news. How do I know
about this? I can't stop breathing.
I want to know the
details. What happened? Oh,
well the guy who did the playboy shoot,
he had a bunch of images that are
unreleased and finally he released them.
That mother Fucker,
especially since you can get
pissed after you've had that,
that porn video either that porn video
was like one of the dirtiest porn videos
I've ever seen. Big fucking
throbbing. Black big. Okay.
Big Black Dick.
Confident young black man who is handsome
and athletic and she was sucking his
hard black Dick. That's a wrap.
You can't complain about anything.
You crazy bitch. You made it,
but I don't know why I know her.
I mean [inaudible] you know her because
she wants you to know her and I fucking
hate it. I brilliant out of
my head. I do hate it, but I
don't. I love it. I love it.
I love the retardation of it all. I mean
we, yeah, we would be out of business.
I didn't have everything in the
world to hate. We would be puking,
but we wouldn't be funny.
We wouldn't be funny if we didn't.
We'd have little name tags on right now.
We'd have to have our
hair cut over our color.
If I didn't know who
fucking Kim Kardashian was.
I don't agree with the whole Buddhist
monk ideology of living wearing robes.
No masturbation, no fun. Because then you
miss out on some of the fun of hating.
You miss out on some of the fun.
There's like an a part of me that
knows that this is the wrong path and
lightened meant when I start shitting
on people and fucking torture them.
But there's another part that
goes, fuck you. Stupid. Fuck.
I'm trying to figure out
the way the Internet is.
It's only a matter of time and it's
actually going on now before the just
regular civilians are open to the
same kind of fucking hate mail. Yes.
Internet trash talking that we deal
with on a regular basis where you know,
you go out to lunch on a date
with some woman and she goes, Huh?
He had puts on her Facebook. He had stinky
breath and he's fat and I was boring.
And she links to your Facebook. Well, no,
the guy's going to have someone from
fucking four Chan finds it and then they
start a thread on animal and it's fucked.
Paul Revolution, he w n e, d, You know,
emailed this guy, you, you're
fucking constellations,
but you're going to find out what people
really think about you and you're not
going to like it.
And it's like change what we take for
granted as just being honest versus being
civil and people are really gonna have
to start just Larkin owning who they are.
I, yeah, I agree.
And I think another thing that's going
to happen is that this is only one stage
and an endless stage of disclosure.
And then what we're at right now is the
beginnings of transparency between all
people and all information of all,
all acts,
everything you've ever done and
everything you've ever thought, right?
We're eventually going to be able to like
literally sink up to one fucking hive
mind that going to happen. Google.
Yeah. It might be Google, right?
Google might be skynet. Yup. Well
whatever know it's, it's, it's
inevitable. I mean everybody
wants to again, make me hard,
ladies and gentlemen is signed.
The keeps falling for the folks that are
on iTunes that don't get to see this.
When Doug and I were on the Mankato,
I know we complained, but this is,
this is pure evidence that was,
that was the best story about how hard
we had a game show that we created called
make me hard.
And it was,
it was one of the best things we
did when it actually turned out.
And the reason why I was one of the best
things we ever did is because there was
tranny cock cock. Yeah. But we, we
the the show is called make me hard.
And then when we actually made
the show and when we, you know,
talk to the comedy central people and
everything, they didn't like hard,
hard was too dangerous.
They wanted it to be make me stiff.
And we were like what the fuck
is the difference is the most,
this was right before
we're about to tape too.
So our department has to rush that.
They allowed fucking full open tranny
cock open tranny cock cause we're going to
blur it out. Simulated fellatio on a
banana by images. This is what happened.
All the language. It's just this
was the Gig. There was a kid,
they would strap him to a chair and
they would put it, this harness,
actually I should back up because a
lot of people probably don't remember,
make me laugh,
was a game show where people tried
not to laugh while comics try to make,
but the guys would get in their face
and say silly things. So make me hard.
We set them up where they have this box
on their package and we would decide
when it lit up indicating that
they had an erection. So we had,
so they had to try to not get a
boner during these sexual, uh, yeah.
So of course it would go off, midgets
would eat bananas. It would go off.
And we had this really hot tranny.
She was so hot that Eddie Bravo and I
were at the comedy store one night and we
were coming down that we've
got a park at the high end.
The comedy store parking lot was
full and we're coming down the ramp,
but she was coming up at eight. He's
going, God damn that pitches on. Look,
this chick coming up right now. Whoa.
She's so pretty. I go, that's a dude.
I've seen his dick.
That's how hot like her name is.
Vanity and choose totally believable.
If you ever think that you
can't get tricked by a tranny,
there's no way I would know. I
wouldn't know. You wouldn't care. She,
yeah, she blew a dude. We know and yeah,
just did it because Weiss, yeah, twice,
once on the set.
And then once that,
and then she called him after she was at
our hotel and he was back the next day
or something. He's so hot. We're
calling him, her name was vanity.
And you can find her like, I
think it's vanity, Tsu, Google.
I've found her to show it to people who'd,
who'd blame him? So anyway, the, we,
the, the guys, you know,
strapped to this table and she climbs all
over him and he licked her tits. Right.
I can't remember. Poor fucking
guy. We tortured this guy's
memory forever. So He's,
he's like, everyone's going,
yeah, yeah, yeah. People cheering.
And then she pulls out this trainee Dick
that looks like, like a poison monkey.
Dick look like it looks sick.
Like it had been hitting so many
female hormones. It was like an old man
in a wheelchair. That's what a tickler.
And she pulled it out. It was black,
it was black. As it functions, there's
a bunch of snow. No, it's done.
It's all done.
I mean it's just hanging out there.
It probably feels good when
you suck. It's still, you know,
even a soft dick feels good if you
suck it right. But I don't think,
I don't think there's any,
unless she pops Viagara maybe she'll talk
for Agora and I still have a hard dick.
Wow. But she's just so full of
female hormones where he is.
Do you know if it's something that's
kind of crazy and I, I, before,
I shouldn't have ever said this, but now
I think I can do it. Uh, I used to read,
start reading penthouse magazine reading
recently and there was this thing at
the end of the magazine that
said, I'm coming next month,
pet pet of the month. Uh,
and then there was this girl's
photo and stuff like that.
So I became friends with her on
Twitter just to follow her around.
And see who this girl is.
And then the following month she
wasn't to the pet of the month.
And then so then I started following
her Twitter a little bit more.
And she's a guy
what? And they just kind of kind of like,
hmm. They just swept it under the rug.
So a dude snuck in and became
a penthouse pet ivy league.
They obviously did a photo shoot
because it was saying next dude's name.
I don't remember man. It was like
it was, you got to come was like,
where's Alex Jones on this? Well I can
tell you what months it was. It was like,
how about this? How about you
Google that shit? Find out what?
I don't think it's no one caught it,
I think.
I think I just noticed it because
I followed her on Twitter.
Why do you think she's a dude?
Because she's a dude, if I know.
Cause you sucked his neck. If you look
at the, if you looked at her and then,
and then she talks about it.
She was talking about it on her Twitter
for talking about being a dude. Yeah.
And then she heard Twitter just
went away. Whoa. They paid her off.
I think I paid her, I don't
know, older. She's fucking,
imagine if you were
seeing drivers allegedly,
let's just say you're a truck driver
and Cincinnati and you beat off to the
fucking July edition of penthouse
and you find out what's up, dude.
He probably got a good lawsuit some
fucking like it was like, well,
[inaudible] tell. I just want to know
why they didn't notice that. It may be,
how can you tell maybe she has
a disease maybe or something.
Maybe she has a disease.
What the fuck does that mean?
Brung it something bad.
Dub World. The whole world.
The fucking sex world. That's a strange
world. Yeah. Yeah. It's pretty fucking,
I don't hate to use the word
shallow. Yeah, but yeah,
it's the, using the word gives a
different connotation than what I mean,
but they're really, there's
not, it's like sex itself.
There's not a lot of ways to
go with it. Right. All right.
I stuck my Dick and I can. All
right. Is that different? Does not.
So the people that are involved in that
tend to be people who are easily amused.
Yeah. What I always said about like
there was a bunch of friends who uh,
they took me to this marijuana policy
project thing at the playboy mansion and
they were all going off. Wow. I'll call to
the man. She know HEFCE the fucking man.
Look what Hef did. Look would have
dad and I and I stopped about I go,
do you guys,
there's a big difference between being
attracted to girls like you are right now.
You guys are attracted to girls.
There's a giant difference
between that and making a living,
taking pictures of them
naked so guys can beat off.
And that's the whole world you live in
and you have a mansion and you pay them
to hang out with you because you
think that it's a cool image.
So you have all these
girls that you're on,
you have the payroll and you're this
old dude. Like you're the fucking man.
One of my favorites bucket bits. You ever
did? But yeah, that was bad that day.
Just something fucking creepy about that.
This creepy about anybody that's,
that's getting money off of other people
being naked and they're rich and the
people who are to pour, right?
Like that's, that's that,
and again, it's all it is,
is fucking nudity and fucking,
yeah, it's like playing a Kazoo.
There's only so many fucking,
you can put a little bunch of
Kazoos together and make it,
cause you orchids is just,
that is true music at the end of the day.
But that is true.
But if you're a young,
raging man with a fucking
throbbing Boehner and, and
a strong sex drive in your,
you know, 19 or 20, you know,
1920 and you're hanging out in Vegas and
you're at a club money in your bank in
new checks every night, that's exciting.
Right? No, it is. It is, but it's, it's,
that is a market that's been created by
the falls and morality and people that
are against sex and make it as
difficult thing to obtain. Right.
If people were just fuck right away
and get that out of your system,
you could like Europe,
like I don't, I don't know.
There was there more liberal.
But yeah, again, you don't
see when you go to Europe,
you don't see the shit we
have here fucking sex in
advertising and titties on a
billboard because it's not built up to
be that big a deal. It's such, you know,
such a a, what's the
word? Fucking holy grail.
Just to see entities so they don't,
it doesn't have the leverage
over there that it does here.
Remember we both grew up in
Massachusetts and a lot of Catholics and
Massachusetts, Catholic school girls.
I mean it's a fucking, it's a joke.
It's a longstanding joke. Why are Catholic
school girls whores? I mean not horse.
Cause why are they freaks? Why
they freaks? They're freaks.
Because that's the last
thing their parents want.
Right? That's the last thing.
The parents want to control them.
The fucking teacher wants control.
They make them wear crazy outfits and
then also on those outfits become hot.
You want to fuck them cause they're
wearing those outfits. I mean,
is that the most ironic shimmer leaders,
Catholic school girls and fucking that,
that outfit. Schoolgirl outfit.
That's the outfit. Like all the guys.
And you're like watching football
on Thanksgiving and like, yeah,
I'd watch it judge for the cheerleaders.
Like you're from a such a repressed sexual
place that just a girl that's vaguely
skippy growing up in the Oh death
I believe. Do you watch mad men?
I'm fucking absolutely awesome.
I it's, it's fantastic. It
really, if you, if you look at it,
it is a glorified soap opera.
But that era
is so well done.
I'm not totally familiar with the show.
I've only seen like little clips out
advertising from the 1940s fifties late
fifties, early sixties. Here's
what I know about that show.
There's a bread head on
that's ridiculously hot. Yeah,
she's pretty hot. She got,
she got fat this year. It's a
big to do and oh, she's gotten,
she's gotten wider in the Lazy Lazy.
It became some big to do where uh,
yeah,
cause people have pointed out that she
got fat and then there's the other,
how dare you say she's
fat than season one money.
Like you wouldn't be happy to be with her,
but the why,
why can't she get fat and professional?
Hot chick up bad.
She's just up saved. She's fat.
Fat is only fat as a description.
You decide it's an insult.
It's a description.
Totally true. Indian, your indigenous.
It's a description. You're fucking tall.
You're short. You're pat. I used
to have a joke about Mexicans.
It wasn't about Mexicans,
but it was about the Roswell incident
where you know the, the aliens,
you remember that junk was, no, I don't
remember the joke, but the joke was, um,
you put Roswell, it's going to be a
Mexican joke. I'm already kind of get,
the joke was that the
government released, Eh, they,
they had a press release to say that
they had a crashed Ufo and alien bodies.
The alien bodies is bullshit. I did it
just to make the joke better. And then,
then the next day they say, they came
out and say, Oh, we made a mistake.
It was just blown. And I say, what
about the aliens? Those were Mexicans.
They were on a blown, they were
tracking some shenanigans took place.
I said that in one night at the comedy
store and this chick yell out, Hey,
yeah, like describing Mexican
as a Mexican. Like, it's a bet.
Like I said,
anything wrong with Mexicans.
I've never had a anti race joke
in my entire life, but any race.
So to think that I would do it about
Mexicans, but just that I said Mexico,
it was like she had a right to stand up,
hands on hips,
long nails stretched out.
Hey,
like she found a fucking, she
found an opening. I had to stop.
I stop my show and address the issue.
Oh,
I still don't know you as something
you're not supposed to say.
My friend Brian wants got mad at me now.
This Brian, Brian Frazier or writer, uh,
there was something happened and uh,
I said I was trying to chew you down
and he's Jewish and he was super,
super sensitive and he got really mad
at me and he was right. I mean, I'm a,
it was kind of a racist statement,
but, oh, but, but you didn't cook.
I'm Italian. And if you said, oh, look
at this fucking dopey Guinea, you know,
with this gold chain and
this stupid slicked hair, I
started laughing, you know,
it's not me. Okay. It's, it's,
yeah. What are you acting
like a Guinea? You know, if I,
if I had a chain on it, he
was like, what are you going,
who are you acting like Guinea? I
wouldn't be upset, but Jew you down,
like someone tried to shoot you down.
That's a particularly insulting side
of a demeaning expression about Jewish
people. And he got that day.
They tried to mark drifty. Yeah,
they're a little bit frugal. No fiscally
responsible. Again, it's a self imposed.
Oh Shit. I'm going to be, he got
so mad once this fucking guy,
this it. Brian was a, he's a really
funny guy. He was a great comic,
but a really high strung guy and
um, uh, it's stopped doing comedy.
I think he just writes now.
But we were in a,
we had a cake together in
Fremont and by the way,
he was a bodybuilder at the time
and all natural but enormous,
like the proof positive that you don't
have to do steroids to get big because I
know this guy never did anything.
He was eating like Broccoli
and never even took vitamins.
But he just was obsessed
and at giant muscles to the
point where I tell him like,
you can't go on stage with teachers on
like you go on stage with tee shirts,
just carrying the fuck out of people. You
don't look funny. You know, like funny.
I go,
you didn't need to wear like a suit or
along a baggy shirt that covers you up.
You're intimidating.
I,
I can't look at anything but you
on stage with these giant muscles.
So we did this gig together on
the road and uh, he had a throat,
sore throat and he was apologizing for
the sore throat. You know, he's like,
I'm sorry to the, to the guy who ran
the club. And um, he, uh, he goes,
I'm sorry I was a bit sick all week,
guys, go please. You were hilarious.
He killed it was great. You guys were
awesome. And, um, he goes, I'm just sorry.
I just really,
I wish I could've done a better job.
He was really just a nice guy and the
guy goes, relax with like a playing,
what are you Jewish?
He says this because Brian had a crew
cut and he has blonde hair. But yes,
he's Jewish. His fucking name is Brian
Frazier. Like Frazier's that Jewish name.
Like you wouldn't even put that together.
But then you think Joe Frazier chooses
a Jewish name is German. All right,
well I have no idea. I wouldn't, I
wouldn't see Frazier and Phil, your heap.
I say Fraiser's a German name. No, isn't
that Jenny? No, I don't know the whole,
it's not Liebowitz. It's not obvious,
but I mean the guy, look, he's blonde,
he's blonde and he does not look
Jewish. Right? And he's a bodybuilder.
He looks like he looks like some dude
you pulled out of a farm in Iowa and he's
ready to fucking kick your ass
and date rape your sister. Right?
That's what he looks like.
But he's a nice guy.
Brock Lesner is what you're
saying. Exactly. You can't say
so he goes fucking nuts and he can't
talk cause it's flushes your fucking ass.
All Jewish and he's red in the face
and this guy can't realize that.
He's telling me he's being serious
for like the first couple of seconds.
I'm like, fuck, what am I
going to do here? I'm like,
what am I gonna fight my friend to keep
them from killing this asshole? I'm like,
I'm here in Vermont. I'm
thinking I'm going to go to
jail. I'm ready to this hall.
And Brian is just big giant tree
trunk neck. No, fuck that. Gosh,
I have Josh any serious. And the guy
has to realize that he's serious.
And Brian is like leaning over the
desk like screaming and the guy's face.
And I'm like, so what happened? I have
to talk him down and nothing happens.
It's fucking anticlimactic
story. Of course. He's Joyce.
She was very upset about being
called Jewish. Yeah, but they don't.
But with the insinuating the Jewish,
well, he was Jewish. People Complain,
they just complain a lot. They're never
going to really do anything. Right.
Why are you, why? Why you have
such a sense of guilt, right?
What are you Jewish?
I'm sorry,
I got that from every fucking
Jewish comic I've ever heard.
That's why I say that. I'm sorry. Yeah,
there's a lot of guilt going on in
the Jewish world. Again, if you,
Ari Shaffir as the best story about
being, you know, Ari was raised like,
like really strict orthodox
Jewish and he had to read the,
Tom would like 10 hours a day.
He lived in Israel,
like he did the whole deal and he said
that they told him that masturbating,
when you masturbate your seed,
when it leaves your body goes into a
demon's womb and gives birth to handicap
babies.
Which is true.
Absolutely true. True. Could you
fucking imagine if somebody that's,
that's what your mom was telling
you and you're like, oh my God,
I know this can't be real, but I
got to go with it. This crazy bitch.
I'm never going to figure it out.
Like walking through the mall and
apologizing to people in wheelchairs.
And when I was in first grade,
I went to Catholic school and I can very
remember very clearly thinking that I'm
fucked because I know I don't
know what life is all about,
but I know these assholes don't either.
And they're the ones who are going to
tell me they're the ones going to tell me
and I'm fucked.
I'm fucked.
Because they're not telling the truth
and they're not right and I'm fucked.
I remembered that, that thought. I
really remember it from being like six.
That's a terrible fucking feeling
for a kid to think that the,
the people that are, that are raising you
are retarded. No, wait, what's going on?
I'm going to jerk off into a g a demons
pussy and it's gonna make a retard baby.
Really? Really? Yeah. You gotta fucking
video of this, you know, could you just,
why are you just saying
this? You just, you know,
because it was written
somewhere and you're gonna,
you're gonna teach me and I'm five.
You fuck.
I always, I, I, I was,
no, that was, sorry.
That was someone else
has just talking to no,
I thought it was just telling him this.
He was that stupid meeting I had with that
lawyer guy. But uh, yeah, I would, yeah.
Doug's Stan hopes lawyered up. Ladies
and gentlemen, I am lawyered up.
Look in high power. Don't get crazy.
The guy showed me that he had a,
an autograft sheet of
acid from Timothy leary.
That's a good lawyer.
Said when that's on your lawyer is warm.
I might go to jail too.
He's going to jail first.
I'm sure it's not going to jail acid.
Did you want to jail first and you have
to wait with the artwork before you
write the book. You have
to wait five years. Right.
So that's the court ordered notice off
it off of it for five years after he goes
to jail. I ain't a fucking
great joke that uh, uh,
there's a statute of limitations.
Like there's 13 more months before
I could do it. Really? Yeah,
I'll tell you off the air. Wow. Awesome.
One of the fucking coolest things
about being friends with Doug Stanhope.
I get to know the joke.
You bitches don't get to know shit.
It's weird having material that
you can't do for 13 months.
While you should know what you should do.
How strong is this story?
How strong is the story? While the story
itself is, is, is strong, but I'll,
this is what I think. There's
one joke, we'll the story itself,
I think this is what we should do.
Actually. I'm actually doing the joke.
I just had to change it around
a little bit. Oh, you know,
it'd be cool though is if you had
a show where you organize a show,
let's say in Phoenix, Denver, whatever,
and pick a city and then told everybody
online and 14 miles or 13 months,
two weeks, I'll be [inaudible].
I do it on the fucking road.
If it were a decade ago, subject
was mother, mother. Okay. Oh,
you know, you know, oh,
the mother does something to you
perhaps could be legally responsible for
something along those lines. Let's
just start. You're talking about,
I'm talking about mother,
mother. We had that wrong hand,
but that's all we needed. Yeah. We had a,
our moms on the demand show
for that. Yeah. It was cool.
It was really fun. Oh yeah.
But uh, I realized that my mom was not
nearly as crazy as your mom. Your mom.
Mom's way more fun. My mom was boring
bread and your mom, your mom's hilarious.
You're your mom used to review porn.
Dude,
we had gotten about Doug's mom reviews
porn was the best bit that we did.
She was so terrified about that.
She moved to La to be an actress and she
did all these independent films for no
money and stuff,
but when it came to working with me,
she didn't even want me there.
She was so nervous about me being
there and me thinking she was funny.
She was great. She was great. Your
mom was hilarious and the whole idea,
just a beautiful thing. It's like you
have this new vehicle for writing comedy.
You can write through your mom and
your mom was going to do it and these
sketches and it's fucking
great. Really. I mean,
the move would be honestly to just have
only, you know only right for your mom.
Everything. Well, no.
She tried to do standup comedy and it
was one of the most terrifying, awful.
That's when I met you. I think she
had been on stage at the night.
I met you at [inaudible],
didn't we? It was called union.
It was next door to double. Oh, right,
right, right. Yeah, you're right.
My brother had gone up to do
open mic and it was so awful.
It was like the worst fucking comedy
you've ever seen and everyone knows me and
I think you were there.
Kinda remember it now it's one of
those things where you just, you just,
how'd you guys meet?
Were you,
what were you doing at the time when
you go with this bar next to Dublin's?
It was, I'd heard about him. I'd
heard about them from a Joe Diaz,
which I use radio. Doug Stanhope so
funny motherfucker. You got to meet.
That kid is good. We, I think
he was. Yeah, that's what,
that's what Joey said. He's one of
us. Yeah. Where it was the real deal.
Where's Joey Hollywood was
the last time you saw him?
I haven't seen him for years. I
tried to bring him tonight. Yeah,
I gotta get his number. I lost all
of fucking when I lost my phone.
What the Fuck Doug Stanhope not on,
I lose my phone.
I twittered my phone number accidentally
send. The guy saw that somewhere.
It's trying to send us a Doug Benson.
Doug Benson was going to the Vegas
for a UFC and I was like, yeah,
here's my number, get in touch
with me and get there. Fuck.
And I realized once I sent it out
that I sent it out to the whole world,
or at least a hundred thousand people.
How's that?
So I got how many calls did
you get? My phone, my phone.
I would turn it on and it would have so
many texts that detects would be coming
in
being,
yeah,
every time I would vibrate with the new
texts it would get to a certain point
where it's like a hundred hundred 50 and
200 and where the phone would just bang
shut off and reboot. Wow. Blue Black.
Where he would go black and it would
reboot [inaudible] they don't have any.
My girlfriend was on my Facebook and it
accidentally when like online's so it
shows that you're online to all your
Facebook people end up fucking chat.
Things just start popping up.
So as I got fucking shut this off,
I don't have that set up
like that, I don't think. No,
you just have to turn it
on yours. Yeah, she had it.
She accidentally turned it on somehow.
I don't mind Twitter and stuff like that,
but you can't let everybody looks like
when we had the chat online with the, uh,
the, the podcast, it was just
too much. Too much access. Right.
So much freedom is fucking anonymous.
Clouds,
broken bottles up there, asshole.
Just smashing keyboards. Fuck, fuck.
You know too many of them man.
Just too many.
That's why I also get into with the
mother thing go the like I would,
I used to be able to tell jokes.
Yeah, I'll take one. Definitely.
I'd be able to talk about shit like that
on the road 10 years ago because they
didn't have the fucking youtube.
Everyone with a cell phone camera.
What you do is you,
I won't tell those stories on stage
because there's one of you little fucking
rat fucks thinks out there that's got
to youtube it and then you then put it
whatever it is. I fucked around
on my girlfriend last night.
I would fuck around our girlfriends all
the time. And if it was a funny story,
I would tell it on stage the next
night cause they don't know my fucking
girlfriend. Right. But now you can,
I'm in Pittsburgh does this, who's,
who are they going to tell? But now, yeah,
it's every fucking show has some little
fucking bitch that as proof to pry and
pointed this out.
And I've been saying it on stage at
bootlegging is not even difficult anymore.
The,
I mean the expression comes from when you
actually had to have a heavy equipment
in your boot and it was
very difficult to get.
Now anyone can do it so you're not fucking
cool for like good fucking tape of it.
Yeah. I mean you were, you're,
everyone's equipped for it.
Every phone you buy has the ability to
record videos for mine I have, yeah,
I have one.
That's the biggest piece of shit.
I can't even really text on it because
I can't figure out how to get a space.
Okay. Texting me, hey, how's that? Yeah,
it does. You're fucking $19. Why are you,
why are you trying to avoid the future?
Well,
because I don't enjoy it.
I don't like talking on the phone.
I certainly,
it's your fucking business of space right
here in the lower right hand corner.
Oh, the lower see the under case
like you along stretched out. Yeah.
Double wide do that. That's a space.
W One f when it first met Doug,
one of the first videos I ever filmed
ever was going to Ohio University and it
was a parents' weekend and Doug,
it was Ed Helms,
Doug and the dude from a Chappelle
show, the real world, uh,
Christian Finnegan and fitting in.
And so they, they think it's a,
they advertise it as that clean,
they accidentally put it on a family
friendly events for parents weekend.
So parents with their incoming
freshman children. Right.
And it was almost a riot and I filmed it
from the back with the shittiest camera
ever.
And it's the worst video quality ever.
But you could see people standing up
screaming at him and Doug just went harder
and harder. It's like, oh,
let's do an abortion mentally.
And it was like parents as
Christ 600 walkouts. Yeah. Yeah.
It was amazing.
That's awesome. I did a show and
I miss those days like having a,
having an audience that
knows what they're there for.
You miss out on all of channels.
Old School Fun that people being mad
at you. I did a a college in Olivette,
Michigan and that was the same situation
where they were told that I was clean
somehow or another Barry Katz probably
told him that cocksucker the booking
agent. I get there, I go on stage, it's,
I'm standing on two cafeteria tables in,
in a,
in a high school cafeteria.
That's where the tiny little teeny
speakers and it's a football college.
They're all football players and just
full of good food like right when I get
onstage just yelling Faggot,
fuck you fucking faggot.
And so I just start lightened dudes up
left and right and when I do this guy
comes up to the,
the corner of stage and the alerts me
and lets you are not allowed to swear in
this show.
There's no swearing and I'm sitting here,
these guys are screaming faggot at me.
I'm standing on two tables. And if you're
pretending that these are real rules,
that you have a structure,
there's special words and are not allowed
with your shitty fucking set up and
this ridiculous. So I turned to
the crown, I go, this motherfucker,
you see this guy right here? He
just told me, what do you guys,
you guys are at least 18 right?
You're old enough to die for your country.
This guy doesn't think you
should be allowed to hear swears.
Do you believe this shit?
This motherfucker right here told me
that I can swear to believe this shit.
And they started going crazy.
I go,
let's burn this fucking place to the
ground to start throwing chairs and shit
and go crazy and screaming.
And I'm laughing and joking
around while I'm saying,
I ain't go no, don't burn to the ground.
So the guy goes, just say whatever you,
Amy is gay too,
by the way.
So I don't want to make it seem like
I'm adding a list for this guy's voice
making the list existed. He
goes, say whatever you want,
don't be consequences later. Wow. That's
what he said. Say whatever you want.
I'm like, I'm going to do what the
fuck I do. Signs you get paid. Yeah,
I got paid and he had to
pay me. Yeah, I didn't,
I written didn't really get paid
cause this was the days of New York
entertainment were buried.
But what Barry Katz used to do is he would
book these colleges and you would get
a check and the check would
be to New York entertainment.
You would give it to New York and
attainment and then would cut you a cheque
supposedly. Yeah. Theoretically. Well,
Barry's expenses got a little out of hand.
So he started spending people's checks
and wasn't paying anybody. But I,
I had done a college gig in yeah,
Tampa and then I banged
the girl who booked it.
So I went back for whatever reason,
I don't know if it's in the same trip,
but anyway, I s she had
booked, it was backs.
I was backstage and it was Darrell
Hammond, think it was brewer.
It was three guys from
Saturday night live. And, uh,
when they get off stage, they are
like, so where do we go to get paid?
And she goes, oh, uh,
Barry said just send,
I sent the check to him and
they all fucking went, no,
you fucking gave it to Barry.
Get motherfucker now we're never
going to see our money. This is,
I did in the late mid to late nineties.
Barry Katz was one of the producers
on the first last comic standing. I,
he's not involved in it now. I don't
know if he is, man think he is.
Maybe [inaudible] name
famous manager. Yeah. Then at
that Dane Cook, I think maybe
it was the first one where it was me. I
was one of the judges, Monique and buddy.
Oh that's right. Yeah. I forgot to buddy.
I got mad at me cause I
called aunt out on stealing,
stealing shit from movies lines from
the movie boiler room about Manhattan.
Some guy comes up to a
gay guy and he goes, hey,
they should put your people on
an island. And he goes, they did.
It's called Manhattan.
It's funny, I have the actual
pilot of the last comic standing.
They had you in it. I have a
copy of it. It is on you too.
I have it somewhere on
youtube. It's called Shit
Funny House. I haven't seen it.
Oh,
I've pulled in my leg.
I looked high and low for the
more Jay more you and yeah,
I did the presentation pilot for last
comic standing and a presentation pilot is
what they've filmed to show the network
what the show would look like if uh,
in order to get picked up. So I lived
in a house for three days with five,
there were five comics total
and we were the comics.
John Heflin was the only one that you'd
know while there's Alex Stewart is a is
a black comic. Yeah. All right.
Him and it was really fun.
[inaudible] I can't remember her name.
And then some other chick
that dates some comic.
So the only one that made it through
to the heffer on one the second year.
Second year, yeah. Yeah. After the,
after the first year. Because they were,
they were acting like, well, if this
gets picked up, you'll be on it.
That's why my manager
talked me into doing it.
It was less money to do the presentation
pilot than to be on the road.
But my manager's like, well,
you know, if it gets picked up,
I mean it's already a presentation and
then we're sitting in the house going,
if this gets picked up, how are we going
to act? Like we don't know each other.
I'll coming into a house to live together.
I go,
I don't think we're going to be on
it if it gets picked out. Fuck Jay.
More fucking
cocky little concert.
Norton Jim Norton was on the first season.
Wasn't anybody had to like leave
halfway through because, uh,
I like to pretend comics that I,
uh,
I don't know cause I left Bisbee
era to, to live in Bisbee, Arizona.
So I don't know what's going on in comedy.
So because I don't know
what they're doing,
I just assume they're washed up and it's
a happy thought. And then I'll find out,
oh fuck y'all get out arenas. I
don't know. I don't watch network.
He shot a fucking TV show. I thought
that guy's washed up. Fuck yeah.
There's a certain few guys. You root root
to crash. Yeah. There's a certain few.
When you find out they're not doing
so good to you. Yeah, fucking prick.
But you have to know it affects them.
You know you're not a Boston
comic. No, not at all.
Grew up in Wooster in Wooster. Tell us
18 as soon as I was old enough to leave,
I put you on Boston comic.
Whether you like it or not,
there's a reason why there's
so many fucking funny guys
from that shitty part of
the country and it's not
shitty. Which shit is shitty.
Yeah, the weather's Shitty.
The girl, I think everything about,
well, not everything obviously hyperbole,
but I did not know the girls
were nice until I moved to La.
I didn't know they were capable of
being nice fucking dumb as shit.
We're hillbillies, man. Eddie
Bravo's, Eddie, probably this girl.
I met this girl in Boston and she,
it was just a fucking Hail Mary.
Sacrifice two in the morning, move way
back in the day. Many, many decades ago.
Anyway, she goes, why? While
he's like making out with
her and pulls his dick out,
whatever, he goes, she goes,
he can't tell you friends,
girls in Boston.
I tell you fans.
That's,
that's what I remember growing up.
I remember the only time I ever got
to fuck with the girls were so sloppy,
drunk and belligerent that it was like,
we had to argue before we get to fuck.
And then when we did it, when it was over,
I was like, Oh, I've got gotta go home.
Get me the fuck away from this. You
better fucking call me. Call me.
Like, there's still like
that. It's the cold weather.
Is it the fucking savages that lived there
that came over on boats from Ireland?
One of my first girlfriends
when I was like 16, 17. Uh,
I kept in touch with her, you
know, remotely here and again.
And I remember I had to be in my
thirties going back and I call in,
we will, yeah, we'll have a drink and
hey, you look really good. And she goes,
yeah. She goes, yeah,
well maybe if you hadn't of Fuck
Sherry Munson would still beat again.
17 years old.
Oh,
that's hilarious. Oh, oh, that's
so fucking funny. But they do.
They hold onto that shit forever.
That's a fucking get
out of jail free card.
It's one of those few pat myself on the
back times in my life is just comparing
myself
to most of the people we grew up with
and knowing that one night in my life
would be something they wouldn't remember.
That would be like the bucking
biggest shit. I don't remember doing.
I've done television shows that
I don't remember. Wait, oh,
you were on my show and I'm
like, Eh, sounds familiar.
If they were on the news
once in the background,
they'd have a still photo of it
somewhere in their fucking grubby or can
Foxborough framing fucking
route nine route nine
the auto mall. Oh. Oh, that's so true.
There's a,
there's a feeling that I get when I
go back to that part of the country.
When I go to Framingham, I'll go to
Natick. You know I mean the Natick Mall.
When I drive through Newton, there's
a feeling that I get lar. I escaped,
got away from you. Fuck
you. Fuck your trapped here.
That's what I feel like in Ohio.
Same thing,
but I have to admit it's one of
my favorite places to perform.
They're fucking crazy and Boston
and they don't give a shit.
They want to hear the real shit.
They had the best comp when,
when?
When I was coming up in the 1980s Boston
had the best local headliners in the
country. They were better. We've talked
about this on the show many, many times.
We talked about it when Dane was on,
we talked about it when a bunch
of different guys were on there.
They were the best comics in the country.
There were local headliners.
Don Gavin was the best comic in
the country at one point in time,
but no one knew it. He was the best,
but I got to watch the guys at HBO.
I got to watch guys when they came in
town and did the live shows and I got to
see Don Gavin. I'm like, he's the
best. He's the best he's doing.
He's squeaky clean and he's crushing,
destroying the point where I feel like
I'm going to quit. I'm a fucking fraud.
What am I doing? I'll never be
like this. And we got, we had,
we were forced to,
to see that like early on.
You know Boston's a very strange place
when it comes to comedy man. Yeah. It's,
it's uh, it's fucking
incest. It's an and says pond
fucking Appalachian Mountain comedy.
Y'All ain't welcome around here.
It's a fucking town of red heads.
We don't send none out.
We don't accept none in,
there's something about it though.
It's a fun place.
Cause cause of the fact that it's so
cold there and it's so fucking miserable
for five months out of the year,
five nights out of the year you're like,
what the fuck are we doing living here?
When you walk from your car to your house,
when you shut your car door,
one
to the fucking house, cheat, grueling. And
you get in your house, you're like, fuck,
fuck, fuck. You shut the door and you
stand there for a couple of sentences.
Summers,
you're fucking wet and full of mosquitoes.
There's one day in fucking October where
you kicked through some golden fucking
dead leaves under your feet and it's that
perfect crisp and you go, God, I see.
I love the change of seasons. No
you don't. No, don't you love that
fucking one day.
And that's the only one you noticed and
that there were other nice ones you had
to work.
You kidding me? Oh, it's so true. So true.
There's nothing worse than working a
shit job in cold weather. Terrible.
I didn't have to get up early to work
a shit job. Did construction many,
many years.
My Dad was an architect,
so like throughout high school
when I wanted summer jobs,
I got jobs on construction sites.
But every now and then, you know,
I would do something in the winter.
And you know,
when I graduated I did a
lot of shit in the winter.
You'd go to these fucking houses,
they're framing a building. Look,
somebody wants to their house built
in January. They don't say no.
They just built a house in January and
you were in like 17 layers of pajamas
under your fucking pants.
You can't move like you're in a space
suit and you're hammering nails.
It's fucking zero out.
Yeah. I never did that.
It's the worst. It was beautiful.
It was the best thing I ever did.
The smartest thing that I ever
did when I was in high school,
right when I graduated high
school at the very year,
me and my friend Jimmy Lawless,
Jimmy got me a job in this construction
site and Jimmy was like a carpenter's
apprentice.
He got me a job as a laborer and I
carried cement bags and pressure treated
lumber for two weeks. That's
all I did for two weeks. Uh,
carried cement bags and
pressure treated lumber.
We were building a wheelchair ramp
at a knights of Columbus Hall.
They needed a wheelchair ramp because
some new laws and all I did was that all
day. And I did nothing. I had
nothing left. At the end of the day,
I couldn't work out. I couldn't,
I just ate. I couldn't work out,
couldn't work out. Jesus. Not
even in my company like that.
Something that you want to do.
After I was eating,
that was back when I was fighting.
I was 18 years old.
I was fighting in tournaments. I had,
I had to train, I had to work out,
so I forced myself to work
out and that taught me what?
All right. I was going to say, if
you can't work, isn't that a workout?
If you can't work out, it's
not enough. You win your dudes.
You're trying to kick you in the face.
You've got to do other shit. You gotta.
You gotta make sense.
Get in there with other dudes
trying to kick you in the face.
You get the timing down. You have to, you
have to stay sharp. You can't just say,
well, I don't need to work out.
I'm carrying bags of cement.
Okay. All right. I would
say I hear workout.
That's you're lifting weights with
the fucking sweatpants on. All right.
Leg warmers. Yeah, but I,
I learned, I learned, fuck,
fuck. Hard work for no reason.
Yeah, no, there's money in
it. I mean, there is a reason,
you know you're doing
it so you can get that.
Some people are predisposed
to that, but, and again,
I know that people that do that
don't look at it like the hell.
It's the same as people who
come up to you and say, Oh man,
that's the scariest thing in the world.
What you do talk in front of people.
I couldn't get up on that stage in
front of people. Well, so scary.
It's not scary to me or I wouldn't
be doing it. Well it's, it's been,
your job is scary to me.
Fucking selling shoes
for 30 years in the mall.
Only to have the place fucking go out of
business. Oh, selling crocs and a kiosk.
What do you do? I'm on the guy in the
mall. I the beat dazzled iPhone covers.
That's pretty good. I make about
60 grand a year. I'm doing good.
Did you use to sell meat or is
that Depaulo depaulo alright. Paul,
one of you sold meat.
Dorna Var and the Polo or the same group.
Angry white guys from Boston. Well. Yeah.
I said fucking white guy from my age,
from Boston. You depaulo was one of the
guys that I got a chance to see, uh,
when I was coming up,
when I was an open mic or he had a few
years and he was like two, three years in.
Who's already really good. He's
one of those guys, Huh? When I,
I went to see him at Caroline's, I
guess it was maybe two years ago. I go,
how the fuck is this guy?
Not Gigantic.
How is this guy not selling out
arenas? He was, but it was the,
it was after Katrina and
then he said, uh, he goes,
a lot more people would've been
rescued if it wasn't for the fucking
misspellings. I looked at this, this roof,
this guy was trying to get rescued
off his roof. It's said hip on it.
You want some hep trick that
fucking won in front of you
fucking howling. Howling. It's a late
night show at Caroline's. And I'm like,
how is this not an arena?
I mean, I've known this guy
for two decades. How was he?
How was he not one of the most,
you know, famous fucking comments.
He is accessible. He's not just
comics clown. He's accessible.
He's got that angry Boston thing, man.
It's just fucking, nothing funnier to me.
I know some dudes probably,
it's probably his fucking personality.
People have to realize like, this is like
the fucking thing. Like, oh, like angry.
And I'm like, you know
what? Fuck man. You know,
just live your life with that kind
of hate. That's really bad for you.
It's not real. Hates
fun. Exactly. Yeah. It's,
it's [inaudible] hepatitis
qualify his personality.
You have to understand this industry
is run by people and most of them are
fucking phony and they know
they're fraudulent. And so a,
a personality like Nick's is probably
very scary to the people who would put him
in an arena. Yes. And so I think it would,
it's probably his personality is
the reason because people are,
that are afraid that they're going
to be found out as completely.
Yeah. They don't want to
go like that around. Yeah.
They don't want to fucking walking mirror.
Nick played my brother on news radio.
Oh, hell yeah. He uh, him and Brian
Cowen and a Epstein from welcome back,
Kotter brother on an episode of News
Radio where we just beat the fuck out of
each other. Like people were, you
know, like we were like someone,
can we cut to a clip of that?
Cause I have to piss desperate.
I think that's why while,
while, while, while Doug goes
to p, Brian, do me a favor,
before you pee,
pull up Bobby Barnett.
Pull up Doug's bit about Bobby Barnett
because one of my fucking favorite all
time bits is your bit about Bobby Barton.
Just see the,
that's what I was gonna talk about that.
And she,
she apparently now this woman from this
bit that we're gonna play is a boy.
If you go to Doug Stam help.com I'm
sure in your archives you can tell your
story. The story is fucking
brilliant. The bit is fantastic.
It's from uh,
keep the edge. Something to take the
edge off. Something take the edge off,
which is my favorite all time CD of yours.
Not because of your materials the
best cause it's, they're all pretty,
in my opinion. They're all
equal. They're all great.
But I love the music
behind it, man. I mean, I,
that was my favorite CD to listen to.
And you,
and that CD you took on this sort
of like a musical quality to your,
your delivery too, like in sync
with the, with, with the guitar.
Henry Phillips and I used to do that
in la just for stories where like know
anytime I was a full story,
I'd try to have him play with me,
you know, goofy little clubs
around and he was, he was,
he was in Houston when I recorded that
and I had recorded every night and wasn't
happy with any of them. And it's Sunday
and there's only about 60 people.
And I went, you know what? Fuck it. Why
don't we just try it with the entire set,
not just the stories.
I,
he had played with the blade to Bobby
Barnett before and uh, you know,
transvestite hooker or whatever. He'd
played behind a few stories, storytelling.
So I just, it was last minute like,
all right, let's just, it's beautiful.
The set feels like that too.
It feels like a set where you had already
gotten enough sets in the bag where
you can be comfortable, you know
when you record something or, yeah,
it didn't give a fuck. Like tell people
if I'm, if I'm filming something,
one of my film and a film in the special,
there's an eight and a 10 got a
10 out of 10 I'm going to be like,
I gotta get this bit out.
I'm going to get that bit out and
getting all technical once 10 minutes in,
I'll be fine. Anyway, don't worry about
the eight. If you've got a babysitter,
18 one one you can make, it'll be pretty,
pretty close, but I'll sit in the words.
But yeah, there's a looseness in when
you know you already have it in the bag,
but you can just go to like tomorrow
night I'm at some place called mortise in
Indianapolis. There's zero
pressure when you perform your do.
It's not a fucking, and I'm a
feminist, but hey, shut it off dude.
Wait until we do it. But the
um, you know, when you're,
when you're filming something man, it's
like a weird, it's a weird pressure thing.
You know, like you am, I make sure I
get this right. I only got one shot.
Like I would never want to do
like Bill Hicks, relentless.
Like he even said that he wasn't
comfortable in it. If you watch it,
it's like it's got great material in it,
but it's definitely not his
best performance and delivery.
It's cause he did it all in one shot.
It was one,
one hour and a half performance ready go.
The cameras are on you.
We're going to film this forever.
Fuck.
It's hard to loosen up and the
crowd is tight cause it's like,
cause they know to the showtime special,
it's filling that Gotham comedy club,
which is a tiny club anyway.
And now it's brightly lit with fucking
giant cranes coming over someone's
fucking cocktail tables
though. I love that place. My,
I've never played there except for
that. When I filmed at, um, uh, the, uh,
southern theater in Ohio,
when I did a talking monkey's in space,
the guy who was the director of it as a
good friend of mine, Anthony Giordano,
he's the,
he directs the UFC and directs all the
UFC like little satellite programs.
And I, he listened to me, I said, I
don't want any lights in the audience.
I want it like a regular show.
Let's just do a regular show
and we capture on camera.
But even then it's hard.
The first one was
like, it was a little stiff. I felt loose.
Like I haven't seen it
but scared to watch you.
I'm scared to watch comedy. Why? Uh,
like I was telling him on the way up,
cause I'm afraid after fucking
this long doing comedy,
I sit there and I go, have I heard this
before, if I heard this somewhere else,
I've told you I caught myself
stealing my own material where I go,
fuck,
this is funny,
but it just seems so
familiar and I'll fuck it.
I'll do it anyway. And then I like
find it in an old notebook. Oh, hey,
this isn't fucking knew I wrote this.
He used to do this
exactly seven years ago.
Yeah.
So like when I do watch comedy at home,
like I'll make sure I'm sober.
I won't go to sleep with though.
I wouldn't dare like the ideas.
We'll get into your head.
My friend Mike McCarthy did that once.
A friend of mine back in Boston,
he went to sleep at the Dennis Miller
CD and he woke up with all these new
jokes. But anytime you sleep
with TV, if you, you know,
your dreams will become
infused with whatever's what?
To bed to fucking sports center.
All of a sudden I'm being fisted by
a linebacker, but so, you know, I,
I'm scared of watching
comedy. Aye. Aye. Aye.
Still enjoy the fuck
out of it. I, you know,
want the reason why I got into
comedy because I was a fan of comedy.
I was going to go see you in Irvine
last night, but I was just too lazy.
I couldn't make that the drive from La
to Irvine at like 5:00 PM his death.
You might as well no fucking
shoes yourself up plan.
Yeah, it's death. But, um,
I still agree with someone.
Like I saw Louis C k recently
at the Improv. I get it.
I get inspired by comedy.
If I see something that's
really funny, I get inspired.
It makes me want to write, you
know, it makes me want to go.
Well that's the other thing is on TV,
it's never as good anyway,
so it's not hard to go,
ah,
I'm not gonna Watch this special cause
it's a special and a special suck.
Well,
what I'm hoping is that eventually
everything will be accessible all the time
and there will be no TV and no sets will
be special because everyone will see
every set ever seen.
Everyone will see everything that you
do ever over and over and over the next,
the next level of technology is not going
to be, you know, something as simple as,
oh here's a newer, faster phone. No,
it's going to be some super invasive
thing while you're allowed to turn on.
You're always on Cam and people could
just travel with you everywhere you go.
And people can watch every
fucking thing you do.
And there's going to be like some
really popular channels where people
subscribed shows zero privacy,
zero none. Total transparency.
There'll be no need for it. No need for
us. No one has anything to hide. Right.
Why are we, why do we have privacy
now? I mean you and I really don't,
you know people who are in the public
eye who talk a lot about their life on
stage,
you have a fraction of the privacy.
Yeah, I don't, yeah,
short of wiping my ass.
I'm really fucking, yeah, I don't
what do you have a good situation or any,
any fucked up situation?
I don't mean good.
I mean anything where it's juicy,
where's there's a story, don't you
get excited? Like you just said,
like you just got a new puppy. When
I got, when my fucking dad died,
I was conscious of the fact that
a huge part of me was thinking,
I'm going to get a lot of attention
for this. And what do you do with that?
Like you fucking, you, you're aware
of that part of you that see like,
right, you're right. But
you know other people do it.
You know they fucking milk fucking
tragedy for attention on some level. Well,
you know, I, I can't,
I can't talk right now.
Something really bad happened with
the insurers. You Go, you all right.
But you know,
like I'm at least aware of
the fact that I enjoy the why.
He used to get excited and when
girlfriends had said go wrong,
cat died or dog got hit
by a car or something.
Cause I knew we were going to fuck.
You're going to feel bad.
I'm going to console you.
Next thing you know,
we're going to be getting afraid gone.
Speaking of fucking,
I fucked a girl named Bobby
by now. Listen, this is one
of my favorite all time.
Stand up comedy bits. One A, one
of Doug's classics, Bobby Barnett.
Check it out. Listen and uh, Doug,
we'll be right back in the meantime,
Bobby Bar,
now it's probably the most,
it just died.
Brian.
Beautiful woman ever match.
There we go.
Something to take the edge off.
Motivation for the clothes.
What's on the iTunes?
That's true.
But that kind of beautiful
girl who works retail
beautiful.
If you life have a flash before your eyes,
you'd have to stop at
that part and beat off
your hand.
Eyes rolled up smiling.
She had short brown hair and big brown
eyes kind of beauty that hurts to look
at.
I met her in this strange bar in
Minneapolis and when I say strange bar,
I mean I didn't know anyone there and
normally I would never have the balls to
approach a girl in a bar
that I don't know people.
My big approach in of of strange bars
to go Sydney far into the bar all alone
watch sports center.
Like the only reason I'm in a crowded
dance club on ladies night is to watch
sports book charisma,
no volume and hope seller feel sad.
But that night, I don't know, I was
motivated or just intoxicated and
sometimes what's the difference?
I talked to her and I don't don't know
what bullshit stories. I gave her money.
I played right into her hand, whatever
she said. I said what she wanted to hear.
She hated long hair.
I was thinking of cutting that
hated cigarettes on is trying
to quit whatever it was at work.
She said tomorrow the twins
are playing the Red Sox,
my team, the red sox. She goes,
why don't we go to the game?
You can stay at my house because
it's right near the stadium,
not for sex,
just out of convenience.
Just exactly what I'd tell a girl
I was trying to have sex with.
So I show up. We had one more drink
in her house and that led to kissing,
which led to grind it,
which led to some of the most vicious
dry humping I've seen since two behind
school was like Horno with clothes on.
It was when it got to a point where I
realize it's not going to go any farther
than this cause every time I tried to
close the deal I can't. I'm not a slot.
Well I am and I'll show you
how. It's not that hard. Really.
Well I don't even know you.
Whoa. I'll have my agent facts.
My Bio along please.
It's starting to hurt here.
Finally I gave up like a gentleman.
I rolled over,
curled up in a warm soft
pillow of my own testicle.
He went to bed.
The next day we go to the twins game.
Twins and play in the Red Sox is like
1994 three if you want want to look up the
statistics prove this story's true.
I'm being an asshole in the stadium cause
I'm already pissed and blue bald and
I'm a red sox fan so I am trying down,
up and down the bleachers.
I go, Ooh, bad side. Yeah,
you're going to lose. And
I keep doing this for six innings,
still a red sox again,
the shit kicked out of them.
They are losing that game.
Five to 100 bottom of the sixth Bobby,
she starts talking shit and so on.
I tried to call her bluff. I say, listen,
red sox lose this game. I will quit
smoking and cut my hair tonight.
Red sox come back and when you turn
lose some of that old plussing girl
somatically than that was stolen.
I said,
as soon as she fine.
Mo Vaughn came to the plate
right out of the fucking phone.
The Red Sox scored out
11 on answered abroad
and Bobby Barnett sat in
the bleachers and turn gray.
She's driving me
silently.
I turned to her and I said,
so do you think guys an asshole
if I took you up on the bed?
But she saying now,
so would you think as an asshole if I
picked up a homeless guy and told you I
wanted to donate my winnings to charity?
[inaudible] made good on the bed,
but it was only
shortly after that she decided she
didn't like the kind of person I was.
I never talked to her again,
but she didn't Welch on the back.
The thing is generally beautiful things
always make me feel kind of empty,
beautiful sunsets and beautiful mountain
tops because there's none of that you
can take with you. You can take
all the pictures in the world.
It never does it justice. You use every
word in your vocabulary to describe.
It never comes out the same.
You had to be there
watching that beautiful mountain top.
There's always a guy next to you goes,
doesn't it make you feel insignificant?
Yeah.
It really does have no need
to feel anymore insignificant.
I feel very insignificant
every day I get that.
I go to my hometown bar where all
my friends know my name and I'd feel
significant.
I don't need anything less,
but a beautiful woman is different
cause a beautiful woman might fuck you.
I went to a beautiful woman fucks you.
It's like she's giving
you part of that beauty.
It's like she's giving you part of
our soul and that is yours forever.
It doesn't ever go away.
You're beautiful mountain tops.
We'll one may crumble to this.
See,
your beautiful sunset might never rise
again by you thought would be Bobby
Barnett. Yes you did.
You fucked me. Awesome.
Repo man with a thousand tow
trucks can never take that back.
[inaudible]
I don't know if I just shut your shit off.
I hit a button on your thing.
Your gadget.
The kids want to get high.
They're just scrambling back
to the microphones now and
uh, ladies and gentlemen,
eyes talking with the Joe Rogan
and a turtle from entourage.
We're discussing comedy bootcamp.
Oh yeah.
Comedy fucking bootcamp. [inaudible]
name's Chris. I'll feel folks in,
if you go to Doug shine help Stan,
hope.com. Doug Stan hope.com.
I think that's one archive back one
archive doctors or a story about comedy
bootcamp. There's been a new trend
in the comedy community as of late.
Is it comedy bootcamp.com?
Is that what it is? Yeah.
I'm not even sure their website,
but they have comedy training classes.
And you disagreed strongly
on the premise and practice.
Yeah, no, I, I think as a,
as a community comics all agree
that classes are bullshit.
Unless they have to go teach them,
then they go, well, no. Yeah.
It's not all bullshit. Right. So yeah,
there's this Guy Kyle cease,
uh,
started a pretty hardcore like traveling.
He got Louie Anderson on the,
uh,
on the ticket as Kyle and Louie
are going to travel. Yeah.
They go town to town.
The way they'll take an Improv for,
they'll get 80% of the door,
uh,
and th th th and teach these comedy,
you have to really read the fucking thing.
So the comics get on stage, so
let's, let me get this straight.
So if they do this comedy class and they
go around the world around the country,
rather say if they show up the Improv and
yeah, Florida West Palm, it's
a comedy all day intensive,
one day,
October 8th that the fucking
Fort Lauderdale funny market.
So there's a hundred people in the class
and they all have to pay how much money
between $403,000
depending on which course.
The one day course is only 400 bucks.
A three day intensive master's stand
up is like 3000 but either way it's all
fucking nonsense. And this I, I,
I've gotten emails from the guy, let's
just assume you've read the fucking thing.
If not,
go to it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and yeah,
pause this and because it's way too
much to get it in your car. Tough Shit.
Just you're going to have to do
the math if you're not a comic,
you don't want to hear all the
fucking discourse anyway. It's really,
it's an inside kind of thing.
But the fact that it's scumbag,
hurry to tell someone,
oh yeah,
I can make you a fucking master stand
up and fucking three short days.
He, they really called him master
stand up mastery is the $3,000 course.
That's strong words. Yeah. Yeah. Mastery.
You're going to be a master of
this 10 years, right. I mean,
I barely think I know what I'm doing
now and I'm 22 years in, you know,
but I know I saw declining it.
If I had a fucking time machine,
I definitely wouldn't recommend you going
back in time any earlier than 10 years
into my camp comedy career, right. Camera.
I can't recommend any of those shows.
Pre 1999 he says you're on your own.
You want to go see it just for fucking
a point of reference to realize that
someone can suck really hard and
come back from that strong. Right.
But I don't recommend those
shows. But, uh, so, so
yeah,
you read the fucking thing
so you don't, you don't think
that there's any way that there's,
there's a benefit of having some sort
of a class to teach people standing.
You can take it, you can get all that
advice for free. That was my major beats.
Anything they will teach you in a class,
any comic is glad to tell you for free
or just at the fucking bar at the Improv
or just get a job at the out at the bar,
the old school way to do it. I agree.
That is the old school way to do it.
But you're still not going to
learn until you do it. Yes.
I want to teach you how to be like you
are. Cause comics aren't like actors.
We're not all going for the same part. We
have to be different. So to take advice,
you're only telling someone
how to be more like you.
Joe and I did attack Kyle cease
brutally because that's my,
the fashion of my comedy where I'm
saying that his family should die.
Something like that.
It's always us.
It's always just to give a little flavor
to the update doesn't really mean that
I don't want your family to die,
Kyle cease.
But I think what you're doing is
negligent, irresponsible and uh, dishonor.
But you,
you
get so upset about it because it's,
I mean,
in terms of like negligent
or irresponsible shit that
the rest of the world sees,
it's really fairly mild. Oh, course.
You'd just get upset about this one
particular subject because it's something
that you love
because I'm calling,
it's something that I know and it's
something I can make a difference.
I can yell about fucking
government invasion of civil
liberties all day and it's
not going to do a fucking
dicks were the difference.
But I could say Kyle sees is a fucking
fraud and it might save you between
403,000 oaks.
No,
maybe it's not a bad idea to get both.
Maybe it's not a bad idea for someone to
go to one of these comedy bootcamps and
you know,
just get turned out.
Look when I didn't know if I was
going to do comedy, you know,
I had been talked into doing
it by some friends of mine.
I just went to an open mic night.
I didn't know shit that open Mike night.
If I had $3,000, you know, easily could
have been, you know, some comedy bootcamp.
Well fuck it, I'm going to
try it out. Like, you know,
when there's 1920 year old kids are,
they're young and they have no experience
and it's not a bad thing to just get
somehow and other introduced to it.
And then once you get introduced to,
you immerse yourself in standup comedy,
he started listening to a bunch of it
and watching a bunch of youtube clips.
Then you read your story on it and listen
to you talk about it and go, oh, okay,
this guy doesn't know what
the fuck he's talking about.
And he just knows what the fuck
he's talking about for him.
Right, exactly. And
uh, I'll give you this,
that it might act as a catalyst to make
you become committed and have always
thought about him doing some momentum.
Yeah. And so, you know, now it's like, uh,
hypnotism to stop smoking.
It doesn't fucking work.
You're not hypnotized.
But the fact that you just laid out $250,
I'm going to tell you hypnotize for 30
minutes might make you not smoke just
cause you don't want to feel like a
Douche bag. So if it has that effect,
but what you're doing is you're,
you're gliding the market.
He talks about how he's got all these
comics now and they're working together in
these communities and they having writer's
clubs together, what you're doing,
you're,
you're saying everyone's innately funny,
which is so horribly untrue.
And what you're doing is giving them
perseverance to keep fucking bothering
bookers and bothering promoters and
clogging up open Mike nights with shitty
comedy because you told them
don't quit. Keep trying. I agree.
You're not fucking funny it whatsoever.
But out of those, like you're,
you're speaking to the
worst case scenarios.
So if there's a hundred
people that take his course,
there might be one or two that sneaks
through the fucking salmon ladder.
They would actually, anyway,
they might, they might anyway.
And they might in spite of, but he
might have introduced them to the game.
He might've gotten them inspired.
A lot of girls are in
porn cause they got raped.
I see your point. When I was starting
out in comedy, there was a guy,
I don't want to say his name because he's
a nice guy. He just sucks. And he uh, he,
one time he was hosting an open mic night
and he came up to me and he was like,
listen, I'm going to tell you right
now, okay, you want to be a comic,
you got to stop swearing. He goes,
you're always swearing. You swear.
Well you don't have a punchline. You swear
to make it funnier. And I'm like, well,
you know, the guys who I liked were really
funny. Like Sam Kinison and dice clay,
you're not die clay. Okay,
you're not dice clay.
And he told me about this one joke he had.
I can't say the joke because
then everybody in Boston
would know who the fuck
I'm talking about. And I don't
know guys, his life sucks.
I don't want to shit on them.
But the idea was that he took this word
fuck out of one of his jokes and it made
it, he had to focus more on his timing and
I don't always like, that's ridiculous.
You're joke sucks.
This is a fucking,
you're telling me how to do you and
I'm even think you're good. You know,
it's like you fuck.
You know.
It's like people will try to
get you to follow their pattern.
You can't do that.
There's no way you can get,
you can tell someone how to do comedy,
but,
well,
hang on then I'm going to,
because we're talking
specifically about Kyle sees,
I don't know anything about that deal.
I should just say this.
I know what I've seen the clips of this.
It's like Anthony Robbins
fucking Scientology.
Believe in yourself. Find your inner
voice. They don't, and that's the thing.
Every fucking comedy. What's the
guy that got in my face at Montreal?
The fucking industry guys.
Step Up. Your stand up.
The guy looks like he's wearing the
fake glasses. The nose, but he's not.
That's Jeff singer. I don't know
who that is. Jeff Singer. He's,
I guess some industry guy and he got
in my face cause I mentioned him in the
update going, I don't do what he does.
He's like, you got your face. Yeah,
he was saying that Kyle sees his shit.
You don't understand. I'm not like him.
Why would you put write that about me?
Yeah.
As I'm fucking awful night at
the fucking Delta borrower,
whatever dealt in Montreal,
it's not the delta anymore.
They moved hotels but it's the same
scene drunk and the guys like fuck you.
Like Hey, I don't agree
with point is Kyle's, Oh I,
we don't tell people how to write jokes.
You can't teach that.
But what we do is we motivate them and
make them believe and find their own
voice. You're still full of shit. They
are full of Shit. They definitely,
and I want to address this because
one of the beefs that I've,
a few beefs that I've gotten from it
is why did you attack him and not Louie
Anderson? Why we just got a little
guy scared. Yeah. Scared. Well,
that's the thing is, and I
sat there, why? First of all,
as I was talking to Hannah, give my
manager and he said, no. He goes,
well,
uh,
Louie Anderson wouldn't be doing
this if it weren't for Kyle seat.
Kyle sees fucking hell.
Yeah.
He got the guy on and Louie
Anderson is such such a feeble guy.
You don't ever look at him as
someone you have to take down.
Kyle ceases the one
promoting this fucking hokey.
The secret I met Kyle cease to the Improv.
You seem like a nice guy.
That's literally all I know about.
No fucking he'd send me
emails and he's fucking tears.
You're one of my heroes. Like you're
not the same fucking washing on me.
I lost into your fucking podcast.
But Jimmy Dore,
every comic that whose name came
up was one of your favorites. Oh,
it's one of those guys. Yeah, he's one of
those, you know, it's funny as hell. No,
look, I can't fault the guy
for not being snow. There's,
and there's a lot of things he says
that I think you're a fucking fact.
The majority of what he says.
I think is good advice.
I don't think it's bad to get more people
interested in doing standup because I
think just with sheer numbers, I mean
there's going to be a bunch that suck,
but there'll also be more, but they're
using it as a scan will be problem.
Like I just started doing a see the point,
but I don't think you
need to be compensated.
If you're going to spend three fucking
days talking to some open makers and it's
going to have to be some, a long cash song
taller. Here's a, here's a crazy fucks.
This is what new comedy,
this is what it really solidified the
fact that this guy is a fucking okay
Connie.
He emails me and he's breaking down how
he's losing money and he gives me actual
numbers where he says we averaged 30,
uh,
30 people per class and if you know,
and then it's $400 times 30,
that's $12,000 and he says,
and will,
and most of that goes to
airfare, hotel, et cetera.
Wait, hang on. You and
Louie Anderson teach class.
You make $12,000 in a day
and you're losing money,
you of all people should not
be teaching anything, right?
How many hotel rooms do you
get for you and Louie Anderson?
You're making $12,000 a day.
What's the et Cetera?
Cause airfare.
That's about 800 bucks for the two years
hotel at a nice place down 400 goddamn
fascinating reality show.
Feel free to steal this idea because
I'm lazy and I won't produce it,
but comedy camp.com traveling,
doing some sort of a like grizzly man.
You ever watch grizzly man where
it's unintentionally funny?
The Guy Werner Herzog had to
know that guy was hilarious.
He had hadn't know what he's putting
together. It's going to be hilarious.
He couldn't admit it,
but he had it know there could
be one of the most beautiful,
Beautiful Cohen brothers
ask reality shows ever.
Louie Anderson and Kyle sees on the
road teaching this funky comedy class
meeting with these crazy open
miker is all over the country.
It's crazy. Standup comedy is
actually kind of getting into a scam.
I don't know if if there's
no money into it or not.
Cause I've been doing it lately and
I'm watching these little open mic,
hers get attacked. But like sales,
like TV salesmen type ways like, hey,
here's the deal. So I run the show at
the comedy store, belly room, all right,
you give me $100 I'll give you a 20
tickets to give to all your friends.
Now you can charge your friends
these tickets, money or whatever you,
so you're going to make money,
but I'm going to be five
minutes and I'm watching this.
You know that's how they do.
That's how they pay fighters and like
low level organizations that give them
tickets. Right? Right. But,
but the problem is is that a,
the belly room is free to get in. So
these tickets make no sense at all. Right.
You know, and so, and so this girl,
she's like always framed the belly
room for the most part. But here's,
here's the thing. This girl's
only been doing comedy six months.
The guy that even came up to her and
said, hey, you had a great set tonight.
I was watching this dude cause like my
other friend Jordan said the same thing
happen to him last time he
was just praying and he's,
he wasn't even watching her.
He came up there and did this whole sales
pitch and like, like, like oh you know,
it's 20 tickets,
stuff like that.
And I feel bad for that.
But I also feel like that's kind
of funny cause it's all so yeah,
it's kind of the fucking ominously
I think less than zero, you know,
con artistry.
And that might be why I get upset at
something so fucking simple as a standup
comedy class, which really has on the
fucking grand scale makes no difference.
It's just,
but I think fraud is the most undervalued
art form con artistry is called,
it's called con art for a reason.
It's fucking art. If it's done well,
there's nothing more beautiful
than hearing about a very
inventive scam rift and
comedy preying on like these little
kids that are set in a comic.
But wait a minute man.
You were one of those at one point in
time and I was one of those at one point
in time when I was 21 years old.
You could have easily talked me into
doing some fucking comedy course. Right.
I would have saved up my money.
I don't take acting course.
I was completely ripped off when I
was 18 I had a bad acting teacher.
That was an earn while you learn program,
they're going to get you
gigs while they fucking,
you paid them to go weekly but we'll,
we'll get you working.
Get yet to casting agents. They
do that with models too, right?
[inaudible] how is it classic took the
train to La as soon as I was 18 with 400
bucks in my pocket,
I get off the at union station
and I'm going to be an actor. What? It
didn't work out when I was in Boston.
Every girl you had a model in photo number
one girls what used to go to modeling
Casablanca.
Yeah.
And they would take the photo with the
girl that's standing like this and like
her hair blowing in the wind and the
poses. They would spend all this money.
It was basically a huge scam when they
would just get these girls to spend a
fuckload of money on getting their photos
taken and then they get their photos
taken with this guy's logo at the bottom
of it and they would send it out and
nothing would ever happen.
But it was like these girls like
camp and doing some modeling.
I mean slink out some new shots.
It's a mildly, every fucking
God damn was models. Crazy.
Bitches aren't even that good.
Tell your friends,
I can't even say early in
the night he was drunk.
She was drunk and I was just trying to
avoid her. I was trying to avoid her.
I was just trying to avoid
her and she goes to me,
you think you're off fear factor.
He's young.
My face with this fucking thing
in the fingers moving. He think
like those girls get sloppy drunk
every weekend. Those are trends.
They know what the fuck they're
doing is fucking just milky,
awful bleach in and
shaved pussies wiring,
cigarette breath and
fucking dirty ass holes.
Still Lou Fain titties black fucking
shearer socks and make your feet sweat and
it's smelling shit
tube top and belly hair,
blue eyeshadow thrown up in the Tori.
Don't leave.
Don't leave
you fucking as though I,
oh
my God.
Can you imagine having a,
if I ran into half the chicks I boned
as a teenager now cause they were pigs
then. Oh Man, I see him now at our age.
Oh I went and found my,
my original high school girlfriend on
Facebook and I opened up her thing and
said send her a message and I went like
that with my fingers and I hovered over
the keyboard and I wanted to apologize.
I want to apologize for being me.
I want to apologize for being 14 I
wanted to apologize for the whole fucking
thing. I mean here, but you know
this is, this is the first one.
This is the first one. And I
looked at it and I'm like, okay,
let's shut this thing off. Close the
window. Like what are we going to do?
I'm 43 years old.
I'm going to apologize for being a
Douche bag when I was 16 you're a con.
Too stupid. It wasn't going to
be this. You got the fucking fat.
Fuck you when you move to fucking
western Massachusetts. I went there once,
I drove an hour and a half. You didn't
even fuck me because you're mad at me.
Shit. I just had that show it did I tell
you what to do? This either fucking act,
no, I'm done. I write it down. Somebody
wrote something down. I had this x
chap me on Facebook and was like,
Hey,
I have something very important
to tell you like, and I'm
like, what's, what is it?
And I'm like, no, I need to talk to you
in person. I can't do this over chat.
And this is from like 12 years ago or
something like that. So I'm like thinking,
all right,
it's one of three things.
They either have a child or I
have aids or she found Jesus.
It's like one of the three
things I'm going to wear face.
I'm going to your Facebook.
And I'm like, all right,
these kids look kind of retarded.
It might be mine. I don't know.
They kind of look,
that kid looks a little Asian or whatever.
So she calls me up and she goes,
Hey,
I just want you to know something
that you remember that abortion,
you paid for it and like, yeah, and
she goes, I just need money for heroin.
I started doing heroin after we broke
up and I really needed money, so I made,
I said this whole thing
that I was pregnant and I,
oh, I thought you said, you told me.
She said she was pregnant with another
guy and it wasn't actually, she said
she was pregnant with her
new heroin friend guy,
but they spent so much money on heroin,
they needed money and I gave her
like $500 it wasn't like regular like
did you ever see the money back hunt?
No.
High dollar seven 50 and suck my Dick
Dude. I said, dude, like interest.
Yeah. You should at least get an
extra 250 bucks in a blow job. It was,
it was crazy cause I sold my Carolyn.
Hey, and then she's off on her tits rot.
That's why a little of my comic books,
I forgot Coles and shoot loads. Why?
I sold my comic books.
I forgot I sold my whole comic book
collection to pay for this abortion. Okay,
well now she's a fuck. She has ruined
your iron man collection. Spider.
What was your favorite comment?
That one has that story. Yeah.
I sold my comic books paper and,
Oh boy. Yeah, that's your story.
It wasn't even a boy.
So if it's for heroin,
anyone who's dealing with anyone who needs
an abortion or heroin should not have
comic ducks.
You shoot a minimal fucking survival
kit like les Stroud around Ranch House.
You just shit to keep your water clean
and a knife to fend them off. Check this,
check this out.
As I was in play a del Rey fucking trade,
my baseball cards kept my
fucking girlfriend a new liver.
I was in Playa del Rey and I was,
I was after the bar closed,
it was that that bar we were talking
about was like 30 people fit in this bar.
And it's just like for locals only,
it's,
the school board has been there since the
19 hundreds so anyways, after the bar,
we're hanging out in this way.
Old Lady 110 years ago. No. So,
so there's hundreds, 10
years ago, the old lady,
this old lady comes up to me and grabs me
by the sweatshirt and she goes,
I see your necklace,
you wear that because it protects you.
And I'm like,
what the fuck you're talking about?
Oh this is the story you were telling me.
I would advise you before
you go into the story.
This is all led to not really say it.
I gotta tell Ya. I gotta tell you,
this is a person who is in the public
guy who got a little fucked up but a
little drunk and made some mistakes.
And I'm just saying if you were in the
same situation and you did the same
situation to a person younger than never,
grab a person and let them lead
you. You get, she was doing it.
We all get fucked up and
we're not ourselves. Okay.
That's the reality of the situation.
The right mixture.
We'll a little bit of crystal math,
a little bit of Jack Daniels.
You can make some mistakes. I want to
say it, but Nancy Cartwright tried to,
oh,
I don't know who that Nancy Cartwright's
the voice of Bart Simpson and she tried
to rape me. Oh, that sound
to tell that story. Hi folks.
I try so hard to save his Karma.
I should just say this right now,
Brian, right now. Can you queue up prince?
I got a broken heart again. Cue this up.
We have to talk. We have to talk.
Brian, Brian's in a situation.
You could just look up prince. I
got a broken heart again. Okay.
You got your phone on. Okay. Brian
is a great guy. He's, I know.
He's a good friend. He's one of the
most interesting people I've ever met.
In my life. I would tries to fuck him
though. So if someone pays his child,
fuck you. It's a good story for
him. It's a good story for him,
but he's right now
vulnerable place. Eat my shorts.
I would eat her short. Brian,
if Brian was on top of the world
like he was just a month ago,
just a month, just a month
ago. Can we talk about how
on top of the world you are,
do you want me to use euphemisms? Let's
just say this. Okay. Let's just say this.
Pretend. Let's just pretend that
a salmon's a song called again.
Huh? What does the song prince
got? A broken heart again.
Let's pretend that there's,
there's,
there's a man and on the
one to 10 he's a three.
I mean he said it's a fucking witty three.
He's an interesting three.
Call me a three. I'm just
making up stories, dude.
I can't make it so close to you that
it's realistic. If I had a judge,
you honestly, I'd say if you lost
20 pounds, you'd be an eight.
Right now you're probably a six and a
half percent. I remember. Is that on?
Is that honest? I was not
mad. Right. Fat The fucking,
before I was nearly this fat,
Brian was a stud when he was,
I was on the fucking man show is
what I was fighting Tonya Harding.
And I remember fucking
him standing with jugging.
Kathy was one of the most beautiful
women in the world and he's like,
look at his fucking body. You're so
disgusting, Dude. Let me look at you.
And that was what I was way less
disgusting. So back in the day. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, so let's be realistic.
Okay, Brian, let me give you,
I'm going to give you a
rating of a six and a half,
seven if you just continue on your
current path of losing weight. Okay.
That's realistic. I don't think I'm
a more than an eight, right? I was,
I was pretty much a nine
when I was on news radio,
but I'm old and my Shit's falling apart.
Okay.
Let's be honest right now I think
on a more attractive than the news.
Radio got a strong nine. Yeah, nine.
So Brian was with a strong nine
[inaudible] you're fucking never agree.
On the chicks because the chicks,
you call it nine and he
showed me a picture and I go,
that's a fucking real doll.
That isn't even snotty.
You're looking for something different.
We have different,
we've always had different opinions on
what's fucking for sure. Yeah, for sure.
We have, yeah. We've always
had like, fuck. Yeah,
some chicks that you would think of.
Wicked.
Skanks I make a perfect
10 what do you like?
What you that girl can I like to, I like,
I like girls with unfortunate tattoos.
There's girls that like just that
there's a porn look now there's not even,
there's, there's no difference. She did.
She was, she was in there like the fund,
this girl,
this girl was some chick that
works at the local fucking,
she works at the local car seat.
Fucking manufacturer, you know,
working in the book. She's an accountant
but she has big tits in this crazy ass.
She has a fake vagina and somehow or
another you get together, you can buy it.
That's what it means, right? It's a
product. It's a product, but you know,
doesn't count with mom issues or HIV.
You get her alone.
Then the next thing you know,
you're a fucking, yeah, you're,
you're banging it out and you're like,
I can't even believe this
girl's let me fuck you. Well,
he had that situation for awhile,
back and forth, a little separation,
little break up. It just wasn't
ready for that kind of frequency.
The kid wasn't ready hit the songs.
Brian, I'm trying your, your Wifi sucks,
does it? Yeah. Really. It
doesn't really work too much.
Joe Hates it when you fucking talk
about his technical ineptitude gadgetry
thing. We need to put a block
by rob tod. You Mow your Wifi.
Joe is about five and a half.
Oh,
don't you go there?
You don't know Mark Merrin's
podcast has fucking Wifi out the
mark. Man. Just send me an email asking
me to do is pop. I probably will.
I just don't want to argue with them. I
like Mark Matt. I think he's a good dude,
but he says dumb shit. I don't wanna.
I don't want to get cocky with them.
That's why not. That's what I want to
argue with anybody. I ain't got no time.
I know, but if you're not arguing,
it's a fucking low rated podcast.
I will listen to podcasts.
Are you doing Carlos men?
Sia on Mark Marin.
I listened to Dane Cook on Mark Marin
and I didn't know you had done Dane Cook.
So I'll listen to that.
And I listened to the fucking,
what train do use name is
that had the Kyle cease on,
you're just looking for train wrecks.
Exactly. What do you want to fucking,
I don't want to the lesson here.
Well listen to fucking two guys who agree
breakdown like the Paul Provenza who I
love women. This is the best podcast
we've ever done. This is the best,
best podcast I've ever done.
And we,
you and I are almost completely in
agreement on everything except the, the,
the level of demonic aptitude Kyle sees
is has it is fucking show. That's it.
I know.
But I'm saying that's,
that doesn't get fucking people I
don't go to listen to. That's okay.
You guys get along. That's
just you, your point of view.
I understand what you're saying.
I understand that. I just don't,
my point of view is at this point
in time, I'm a, I'm a grown man.
I don't want to play these stupid games.
I don't want to argue with anybody who
just don't just stop, stop. I don't,
I don't want to hear it. I don't care.
And I can't,
I've thoroughly dissected my own personal
thoughts and I don't want to deal with
the mess that's in your head.
Okay.
I don't want to have to fucking sit
down and go, well, okay, let's back up.
Where did you come to this perception
and how did this start out?
And maybe you didn't take into account
how I felt. I don't want to care.
I've got no time. You know, he's
doing one of your bits therein.
He did his show and um,
he hadn't been seen on and he had this
like ramp up or he like gives his take on
it and he said the men Sia incident
was two bullies arguing over bullshit.
That's how he said it.
And I just said,
done,
done.
That's it. You just saved me weird
conversations for the rest of my life.
Just don't like to talk to you anymore.
I don't have to talk to you tomorrow.
I can wish you well. I'm Karma free. I can
say good luck. Have Fun. Take care. Don
done.
It's nice. It's nice to, there's
a lot of problems in this world.
You can't fix them all.
Sometimes it's good to Jess.
Now let's go back to Brian.
Brian, his good friend I met
Brian Online is talented.
He makes these incredible videos and I'm
like, what do you do man? He told me,
he goes, I, I worked for
gateway. I was like, dude,
you need to come work for me. I don't even
know what the fuck you're going to do,
but we're just gonna make some videos.
We're going to make shit happen.
We're going to have some fun. Just come
with me on the road. We'll films are shit,
man. Fuck that crazy job. That job
sucks. He's like, okay. Years ago, right?
So while ago, so he comes, he Compson
brands out there and new world, man,
we're traveling but Kona,
fucking comedy clubs and going on
TV shows going all over the world.
We go on. Opie and Anthony were in New
York. Okay. We're all over the place.
Brian's from Columbus,
Ohio.
And this girl is from Venus perhaps.
Maybe. Perfect. Right. Perfect girl.
Your perfect girl. Yes sir. What,
what the fuck would ever make you think
that you would be able to fuck her?
Right, right. In real life.
It's like how does this happen?
How does anybody get the fuck doesn't
have a weak channel, strong eyebrows body.
How does anybody get the fucker?
There's certain girls in this world,
like any girl that's over a nine
it's like really any guidance.
Fucking I was like really?
Because every guy that's fucking at nine
it's fucked sixes and fives and can't
believe that anybody who
talks to him anymore.
But as a whole fucking Bobby Barnett,
he never wrapped up cause you're outside
smoking all the Bobby find that tape.
Yeah, go with bags. Like three, four
archives, genius. She finally found out,
someone in my fans from Sweden actually
tracked her down whether new fucking
married name and she heard that bit and
is a born again Christian now and said
to very upset emails. So
that's it. Doug. Stan hope doc,
which by the way made the bid
20,000 times better. Yeah,
it was beautiful and your
was just fucking spectacular.
I honestly think that you
have to do that on stage.
What I think you should do is play the
original recording on stage for people
who don't know, for the new fans. Let them
hear that and then tell the new store.
Just do.
Then you'd been on states.
A fucking destroyer I think you should
close with that would be pretty fucking
lazy. I go, well, first you to this bit.
I won't say that. You can say you
can say it. I don't mean that.
I mean I feel weird telling old
joke. Oh, I did too. I won't do it.
More weird to go. I know I could
say this. Let me just hit play.
I do old bits at during my question and
answer after I've done like an hour or
so. I always do a question to answer
because at this point in time,
I mean I joke around about it onstage,
but this is in order to keep a real
honest relationship with all these people
that come out to see me,
I don't think I should be doing the one
that gets a talk. I always say that.
I would say this feels weird, like the
whole standup comedy, the the, the,
the whole art form is you get
onstage and there's a microphone.
There's a bunch of people that pay to
hear you talk and that's ridiculous.
You're going to be the only one who
talks for an hour to cocaine dream.
It's crazy.
I get to fucking get to do the coke and
now it's my sentence for an hour and you
don't get a chance.
I always talk about it,
how I understand that this is a
ridiculous relationship and in order to
compensate for the fact that it's
ridiculous, I do the best I can.
I write the most shit I do.
I explore the most ideas.
I tried to give you the most shit.
I got the most hyped up for the show
and I also do a question to answer why.
So she yell out anything you want, we'll
talk about anything you want. You know,
and, and that's, that's like an
opportunity for people to, they can,
they can yell shit out. They can talk
about anything they want. If I were,
if we were going to do, I'm sorry. That's
what I do. Old Bits. This is a, this,
that would be a perfect time
for all of us to fucking do.
If I knew other comics would do this,
I would do a fucking Q and a at the end
of every show for wannabe standup comics.
So you can get advice for fucking free.
That's all you should ever
pay for comedy advice.
That's not a bad idea everywhere.
But you know what you know and not
be a bad idea. If you said, you know,
he had people sign up for an advance.
They couldn't be just somebody who wanted
to photograph no photos, no autographs,
can't waste any time.
But after every show there'll be one half
hour Q and a section session for want
to be stand up comedian.
So,
so you have to be honest about the fact
that you want to be a comedian and if
you are, you're allowed to
common. There's a Roman,
there's 100 of us and we're going to sit
there and I'll let you talk for half an
hour. Right? That's a
great idea. You know what?
You fucking wait outside for
a half an hour after the show,
like fight club and that'll get rid of
the Douche bags that are just drunk.
You want to fucking say something stupid?
Wait out on the porch like flight club.
While if you really want to fucking
be a stand up, we'll give you,
that's how I avoid crazy people at my
shows when I take pictures with them
afterwards I sit down for 10 minutes,
take a leak,
have a glass of water, just to let
everybody just really fucking frantic.
Just go about their way.
Right.
Let's do fucking gyms all over
me with your douchey miss.
Yeah. You sell merge? No,
I did a couple of times. I've sold
a DD hats fucking tradeoff. I can
either sell,
merge and have to fucking dive right
into this right from stage and that head
full of, you know, and then right
to politician. Nice to meet you. Oh,
I'd love to fuck you.
Take a picture with your wife.
Right from fucking are you go.
All right. I cannot sell merge.
First of all, merge sales. It's not
just the money that you're making,
it's the fact that you're getting
your product out there, right.
I'm not on fucking television.
You're all people finding me because
someone sent him a link to a cleaner way
off now. Okay. I disagree.
You're not off the grid. Okay.
You're on the Internet, man.
You're not an internet. I'm
saying this is, this is,
there's a website that I frequent all the
time called mixed martial arts.com and
uh, it's has nothing to do
with you. And there's a,
there's a section called the underground
where they talk about MMA fights,
but there's the other ground where they
talk about anything else and they always
have sections on comedians and
your name comes up all the time.
And I understand that, but I'm saying that
you, you have to feed that sense. Yes.
Yes. I agree. At the same time,
a million people have said,
I never even heard of you.
Sorry. No offense man.
I never heard of you until my buddy
low your DVD. Yeah. So yeah, it's,
it's getting that out there. So that's
the other important thing about birch.
You don't, you don't give a fuck about
torrents or anything like that, do you?
Do you ever,
you don't an idea.
I don't give a fuck about that shit
when people have my shit on my phone.
Every camera. No, no, no. It is computers.
You don't know what a bit torn is where
you can download movies. Oh, stealing.
Yeah, still. No, I'm all for stealing.
And this is what it's not stealing.
Well listen,
listen to this skill from the fuse and
you'll agree with me and this is fucking
very important.
I encourage you fucking downloading and
sharing and burning files of all the
shit that I've released,
but don't come to the show.
And you decide when I'm releasing my new
CD on your fucking cell phone camera.
I agree. That makes me, I
agree. It is annoying. However,
I also think that it looks as long as
everybody else can just deal with the real
hardcore fans of you're gonna go research
these videos can deal with the fact
that this is material that's in, it's in
development. You know it starts out here.
Maybe you want to watch them
develop and that's all cool too.
But don't fucking go to shows and yell
out punchlines when you know what they
are.
Cause he saw a clip on youtube and the
bid is only a month old and it's going
through some metamorphosis.
Like don't be a Douche bag.
But as long as you're not a
Douche bag and you come to a show,
I don't mind if you, you
know, I don't mind all the,
I had you down for a reason
cause I hate looking at myself.
So when I see someone with
a million reasons, I agree.
I'm worried about how I look.
I've taken me totally.
I would take you out of your day if
you're fucking had seven 11 I just start
filming. You have no reason. Absolutely
agree. It's really distracting.
It was the Ice House in Pasadena
and I yelled at some lady,
but I wasn't really mad, but I was like,
he can't just fucking live your life.
Don't fucking live your life through a
fucking youtube clip. This is ridiculous.
Just just enjoy this moment.
You don't have to relive it or
live your three rows away from,
I don't affect you enough that you can
remember the shit that I said then it's
not really worth it.
Just to enjoy the good feeling that you
had while you were there and come see me
again to see. I'll have to fucking
live through a Goddamn Lens. I've said,
I've said the same thing I've, I've said
don't fill me in so many bucking ways.
Now you actually have bits on it, right?
Your bits of people filming? I've had,
yeah.
I've had a number of bits.
I have more bits about about stop
filming me than overpopulation.
Again, can't be honest.
I can't tell you stuff.
I can't say that my
girlfriend's sister is. If I,
if my girlfriend's sister was a fat cunt,
you couldn't do a bit about what does
she do is she was a big fat cut and did
something really awful and
I wanted to talk about it.
And you have can't talk about
my fucking nephews kind of
say no, no little loony violent. He,
he looks at the moon a lot. Nice.
I said,
but I could never do bits cause he,
he's kind of an idiot savant.
He knows how to use computers.
Some people in my life that are hanging
onto a thread because I'm thinking about
throwing them down the river.
I'm talking about chucking them under
the bus and do it a fuck closing bid on
them. There's a few people in my life
where I think about how crazy they are.
I'm like, motherfucker, I just want to,
you're going to be my closing again.
But you can't cause it fucking
hurts when it comes back. Yeah.
You don't want them to be upset people,
you know, you can make fun of me all day,
but making fun of other people, man, for
people, making someone making fun of you.
You don't even know them for most people.
And it's like for us it's like you
just get like, don't Google your name.
Cause if you do some anonymous Douche
bags can be mad at you somewhere for sure.
And I hate myself so much.
That's just a voice seconding
what I already thought.
This is what I find that I'm
sure you find the same way.
Do you find yourself like hating yourself
the most when you have to edit your
shit when you have to like go like edit
a DVD or something like that and you
watch your bits over over January.
Oh you shut the fuck up. Yeah. No I,
I might, I can't stand a fucking
way. I look, people just sound,
we're egomaniacs are narcissists. It's
like when you, when you're editing your,
get to a certain point in your comedy,
I think when you get to a certain point
where you really kind of appreciate what
this is all about and this is really not
all about all this personal intention
that's really not all about,
you know, people loving you.
It's really about like finding a way to
tune into all these crazy ideas so that
other people get enjoyment out of it.
And when you hear yourself do it,
you hear yourself say it, it's you.
It's you saying it's you doing it.
You're judging yourself. You're
like, shut the fuck up. Yeah. No, I,
I don't like doing comedy.
I really don't.
And lots of really though you do though,
you say you don't, but you do. I know you,
if I could bullshit,
you wouldn't do what you don't want to do.
You can tell you like it.
There's moments you like you don't like,
you might not like 40% of it.
Okay.
There's loads going on stage
crush. You love it. Yeah. No, no.
Come on. When you knock it out of the
park, when you really find a fucking,
but when I knocked out of that
really locks into people's
heads and they go, yes,
fuck yeah. But I've, I like everything
that I've been passionate about.
I've beaten into the ground, right? I've,
I can't fucking do another overpopulation.
I'll probably find a way to help you,
can help you with all of these things.
I can help you with all these songs. No,
I do it out of the parts of me is when
I come up with something off the top of
my head when I actually riff and I get a
couple of fucking lines that's knock it,
I can have a shitty show, but if I said
something that amused me like, Oh fuck,
that was fun. That's
funny. You just need them.
When I say write that down to
someone in the fucking audience,
that's when I'm knocking on
it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But
those moments are worth it.
All those moments are worth it all where
you are the fucking lightning rod and
the bolt hits you out of the heavens
and you get this thought when you're on
stage that you really never
went down that avenue before,
but all the sudden you'd
go there and the audit,
it just destroys your howling laughing
at the thought that you didn't even,
you don't even know where the fucking
came from. He could scarcely take photos.
I was just saying to someone that,
the applause that you hear before
the show, when they announce you,
Doug's Stan hope and you hear that fucking
massive round of applause is nothing
but fucking terror of expectations
that I don't think I can meet.
Yeah. I don't feel like that's
love and I worked hard for that.
I feel like they want more than I have to.
That's one of the problems that you had
with the Kyle sees comedy course and you
use a brilliant example where you're
talking about David Tell who's one of my
favorite comedians and your favorite
comedians and one of the most unique guys
in my opinion. They'd come along
lot a little records, his set,
he still has a fucking mini recorder
and he listens to his sets after 20 some
years of comedy.
Yeah.
And he gets mad at himself and he doesn't
like his bed and he doesn't believe in
them and he gets upset and
he gets insecure. Meanwhile
he's brilliant, you know.
And that was the example that you use that
you don't always have to be confident.
That's not true.
Like sometimes you can just do it and
be ashamed of everything you say and
ashamed of every laugh you get. It's
still, it's still formula man. Yeah.
A lot of guys are only successful
because they hate themselves so much.
There's no formula for
anything than any of us do.
[inaudible] head Hedberg funny that as
soon as they became successful dive set
another fucking word. Yeah, a lot
of them. How about a lot of them?
How about a lot of them forgot
what it's all about. Right?
In the reason why the forgot what it's
all about. It's cause he's fucking,
people are hungry at one point in
time they were that were really,
most comedy comes from a place of fear
and hate and it's just a matter of chips
come perspective.
In my opinion.
Ma Hedberg Hedberg was at a pers perfect
example where you look at that guy on
paper, like the shit that he would say on
paper. Like the joke about doubletrees.
Yeah. You know, how did they, do they
have a meetings? How did they name that?
Let's call it two trees. No, let's
call a double tree meeting adjourned.
It's like she'd be funny.
Why is that funny?
I mean while I'm alone in my car, laughing
my ass off and I hear it on Xm radio,
there's certain guys that they just, they
find out. Joey Diaz. Perfect example.
You've said at best you said Joey Diaz
could read the phone book and there'd be
funnier than 90% of the
comments [inaudible] guys,
you don't think you did Wayne that term?
No,
I think that might not have yet is a term,
but I read shade.
Expression is I didn't want
to get, Oh, I'm setting forth.
You said it best when you said
it and I heard I can't say it.
Third hand you can say it second hand.
I can't say it. Third Day I had to take,
I got you and I have to go. Do I have
to do soon? Six, 10 let's find a closer,
but let's talk. Let's talk about a
question. You know, here's a six pack.
I think we drank a lot of beer.
We drink all of them.
I think I'm pretty fucked up
yours over there. By the way.
This is the only time I've ever been.
I need to,
this is only a time drunk on a podcast
and on top of it stops you in the middle.
Do two of these big ass bitches. Didn't
have anything to two here. You know,
it's 6:00 PM. I've had,
oh, I had eggs, lies, lies,
lies, had pancakes today. Headlines,
she and some Chinese. Chinky.
Um, so here's, here's, hey, Kyle sees
I didn't love it. Yeah, I don't shit.
It's not, it's not personal. Listen,
you know, you could do better.
We know I can do better. You can
do better. We can all do better.
Kyle sees you can do better.
Okay.
Maybe just cut down the hyperbole.
Yeah.
Comedy master. What the fuck
dude? Master after three days,
that's what they were getting on
him for. His podcast was a, uh,
there's one clip of him. It's a
montage compilation reel for his class.
He goes, do you want to make $1 million
in your first year of comedy? Oh No,
it doesn't say that. Calm seas.
Fuck you Kyle seats. Yeah,
that's ridiculous. Kyle sees that's
bullshit. I know you're a delicate flower.
And we all, are you going to be okay,
stop doing that. Just do comedy.
The last thing that I want to talk about,
and this is,
this is a sort of a
reoccurring theme and um, the,
I think one of the reasons why you don't
like comedy and one of the reasons why
Connolly bothers you is your
really fucking good at it.
And this is just my own theory. I think
when you get really good at anything,
you don't feel like you deserve
any of what you're doing.
And I think when you get to this point
where all these people are pointing at
you and go, oh, he's fucking awesome,
he's the shit and you're the fucking man,
and you get these Twitter messages
and you're like, ah, okay.
It becomes creepy because you know
that to be really good at something,
to be, to tune into something like you do.
Like I'm a fucking comedy kind of sore,
right? I've been doing standup
comedy for I guess 22 years,
22 years now.
I've been doing it and I've been
watching it for much longer than that.
And you're one of my favorites, so I
know that you, you're tuned into it.
I know you're tuned doing,
do it,
but when you're tuned into
it and onto the really,
in order to really get the energy,
the creativity,
that in order to really
fucking tap into the Muse,
you've got to think
you're a piece of shit.
You've got to think you're not worthy.
You got to think that it's all bullshit.
You've got to think that we'll fucking
different. Who the fuck am I and what is,
you can never think you're the
shit when these guys get famous.
That's what happens.
That's why they suck.
They get famous and everyone tells them
the sh they're the shit and they start
thinking they're special and they start
thinking they protected and they don't
want to dive into the fucking
sea of humanity in labs one.
It's not funny that true. That's true.
Yeah, that's true. Uh, but I, I have to,
I will enjoy it more when I can get back
to a place where I'm not worried about
living up to expectations.
Cause I used to fuck off, man.
That's in your head dinner
like while I'm doing on stage,
I'd fuck that Shit's in your head.
I think you don't get past those ideas
if you just take care of your body a
little bit better.
There's a lot of stress that comes
up to me when I don't exercise.
The only energy that's coming, the only
like feeling of expectation is all this.
There's the performance of
the show and the energy,
all these people and it's like there's
not enough other physical activity going
on a lot to pitch me the Joe Rogan comedy
workout comedy bootcamp that you too
can be powerfully funding.
I'm flashlight of partially
sponsored by fish.
Died not be dicks. No, I mean I,
I mean it sounds very
cliche and hippie and yoga.
I really want to bring this
back to my girlfriend habits.
I brought you something baby.
It's realistic. It's modeled
after mine. Say No more.
It is your is yours.
I'm gonna fuck this vampire mouth.
But you can have this fake rubber Dick.
That's all you know.
Fucking love of fuckers. There's,
there's a balance to all of it.
And I think we both, we both
seek the balance in, in, in, in,
in as you're holding this a rubber
vagina that's on its period. No,
cause I'll fuck with this shit
out of a girl in a period.
It's like saying something, a rubber band
that as big as a house, it's like, yeah,
it's realistic, but it's way too
big. Go ahead. Um, I think, um,
I don't fucking say, all right,
let's not deconstruct cotton.
Deconstructing comedy.
I'm,
I'm just trying to say that I think
this whole thing is we all do in comedy,
it's all about tuning into the idea
that's relevant to you. Tuning into the,
whatever you're saying on stage that
hits you. And a lot of it doesn't.
And a lot of it makes them laugh and
it doesn't make you laugh and it's like
you're trying to find this fucking spot.
But it's all the same thing.
We're all just trying to like just go,
just get to the pure shit,
tune into the pure shit, tuned
into the pure idea, you know?
And then there's always this bag,
big battle with yourself
when you're doing that,
you know there's a big self hate
thing and an insecurity thing.
And then when you all know
those people fucking love you,
but you're the same guy when
you were shitting your pants,
when you're in your car and Oh yeah,
I don't have like famous shoes
or anything like that. I just,
I didn't even famous shoes.
[inaudible] do is expectation that
his fame though, expectations.
A few whom are level,
it's not a matter of it doesn't.
Fame doesn't have to be worldwide.
Shit. Fame can be neighborhood.
Fame can fuck you up. You can think you're
some phone number that found runaways.
Remember the hot whore I said
was waiting coke at the fucking
show. I'm going to have to do
it now. Do it. Do what now?
The coke, the coke like, yeah.
It's like you gotta get Outta here
at six 15 I got rush hour tonight.
Ladies and gentlemen, if you're one of
the best comics work in the country today,
it sounds like
fucking Hollywood bullshit.
We're blowing smoke up each other's asses,
but I really do.
I'm glad we're friends and you,
you inspire me and I love talking to
Ya. And, um, I love what you're doing.
I love everything you're
doing. I have always, uh, I, I,
I mentioned you on the road.
All right, this is going
nowhere. Now. Every time I go,
if I have a talk about fucking
and anyone who has kids,
I don't have friends that have kids
because as soon as they have fucking kids,
I don't talk to him anymore. And I'll,
I'll always say, except for Joe Rogan,
he scares the fuck out of me.
I still talk to him.
He can have as many kids as he walks.
You'd be upset at me if I had kids,
but didn't
if, uh, if it wasn't an intimidating
guy, is that what you're saying
about once people have kids, they tend
to drift in other directions anyway,
and I don't,
I was myself
before I had kids. I think a lot
of people are not themselves.
They don't understand.
Yeah.
Well, they want to incorporate
their kids into your,
and I fucking despise children.
The younger, the worst,
like babies. I was
fucking terrified. I go,
I said to Brian and then
this Brian, I like, fuck,
am I going to have to look at his baby
because I'm going to have to pretend like
if I, someone came to my house and
I go, these are my dogs and they go,
I fucking hate dogs.
That would bum me out.
So I'm going to have to be do the
right thing and look at his kid.
But you didn't fucking
make me look at the kid.
And I think kids are fucking fascinating,
man. Look not to me. I you say that.
I know you say that. Well, I mean some
things are, music doesn't fascinate me.
Kids don't fascinate me.
I look at other things.
Exactly the same position where you're at.
Dying people fascinate me.
I fucking love people dying.
The ideas.
Fascinating idea that there's two
people in the last three shows I've done
including last night I'm dying of cancer.
He came up like the end.
The guy was obviously
fucking dying of cancer.
Great Way to end the show. Some mother
Fucker, but it's not a bad way to end.
That's a fucking,
that's exactly the only thing I love about
comedy and the Fan Base I've created,
the audience that I have is,
that's not rare.
My shows attract people that are
that fucking out on the fringes or,
or in the darkest places of
life that come to see me good.
Not just, but not just there's,
I know a lot of, so, yeah.
No, but I'm saying smart.
We love your shit. I do agree
though that you're, you're,
you are so honest and so out there and
so, you know, you're, you're, you're,
you're tapping into it to the point where,
I don't know,
I'm not on message board,
but this is fucking such a
suck each other off fest.
There's going to be three
pages of your message board.
Why don't you suck each
other's Dicks and board. Yeah.
You fucking love each other.
Not huggers. Fucking of course.
Make me hard is in the fucking
background to that. This
is an interesting conversation
backslash none. Hungary. All right.
Please check out my friend Joe
Rogan's podcast. You're already on it.
They're already on it. Oh yeah. Well.
Doug stanhope.com ladies, gentlemen, uh,
Doug, Stan, hope on Twitter. Um,
Doug Stan hope is appearing at Jon Lovitz
comedy club tonight and tomorrow night.
Tonight is Thursday. What's Today's date,
Brian? September, Thursday and Friday,
23rd, 23rd and 24th in Hollywood
tickets still available.
You can get tickets online at
John. What is it? Google that shit.
Fucking figure it out. Yeah.
You don't need to find it.
You don't need to come to the show.
All right.
We got to talk about
some shit off the air.
Thanks to the fleshlight
for sponsoring our show.
Thanks to Brian for keeping it together.
It's been a tough week.
Thanks to Doug Stan. Hope
for coming on finally, right.
Best podcast we've ever done.
Love you bitches. Bye Bye.
[inaudible].